thank you
have you ever been Amazed by how Google
home and Amazon Alexa assist in finding
information when asked over Voice or
have you ever wondered how e-commerce
companies send you personalized emails
for shopping suggestions based on the
products that you bought online recently
well it's all because of machine
learning that these virtual assistants
and product recommendations work swiftly
in this video we're going to look at
machine learning roadmap for 2022
we will give you the step-by-step
process that you need to follow to build
a successful career in machine learning
so before we get started make sure that
you subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn
so what is machine learning machine
learning is a subset of artificial
intelligence that uses data algorithms
and statistical techniques to build
intelligent systems these systems
learned by themselves and improve with
experience
the goal of machine learning is to
create computer models that can imitate
human behavior machine learning has
found its usage in almost every business
sector from self-driving cars Medical
Imaging and Diagnostics speech
recognition facial recognition to online
fraud detection all of these are
possible because of machine learning in
recent years Ai and ml technologies have
made several breakthroughs and the
rising demand for AI applications across
different Industries has led to the
significant growth of machine learning
as for marketsandmarkets.com the machine
learning Market is expected to grow to 9
billion dollars by 2022 at a cagr of 44
percent
another report from
verifiedmarketresearch.com suggests that
the machine learning Market was valued
at 2.4 billion US dollars in 2019 and is
projected to reach 47.29 million USC by
2027 growing at a cagr of 44.9 from 2020
to 2027. keeping these facts in focus in
mind let's look at the roadmap and
critical skills required to build a
career in machine learning
first and foremost is programming skills
for a machine learning engineer
programming languages form the building
blocks to develop complex machine
learning models
you need to learn at least one
programming language preferably python
or R you should be familiar with various
computer science Concepts such as data
structures including stack queues trees
and graphs algorithms for searching and
sorting Dynamic and greedy programming
space and time complexity Etc you also
need to know libraries like numpy pandas
matplotlib Seaborn depler tidier and
ggplot for data analysis and
visualization
the second skill you need to possess is
Applied Mathematics while solving
business problems using machine learning
you have to use machine learning
algorithms to understand the mechanisms
behind the algorithms you need to have a
good knowledge of mathematical Concepts
such as linear algebra calculus
statistics and probability
so mathematics in machine learning is
not just processing the numbers but
understanding what is happening why it's
happening and how to obtain the best
results the third skill to become a
machine learning expert is data
wrangling and SQL data analysts and
machine learning Specialists often work
with raw data collected from various
sources that are not fit for analysis it
has been observed that 80 percent of
data analysis spend too much time on
data wrangling
so it's crucial for machine learning
experts to clean structure and enrich
raw data into desired format and make it
ready for analysis using data wrangling
techniques
SQL is another crucial set that you
should carry
machine learning tasks involve using
data stored in the form of tables that
are present inside relational databases
a good understanding of SQL commands
enables you to store manipulate retrieve
and handle structured data
the next skill set is machine learning
algorithms it's incredibly essential to
grasp all the standard machine learning
algorithms
implementing any machine learning
techniques requires choosing the
suitable model determining the correct
learning method and an in-depth
understanding of hyper parameter tuning
so you should be really good with
different supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning algorithms such
as linear regression logistic regression
svm KN decision trees K means clustering
Etc now coming to the final scale we
have data modeling and evaluation the
objective of a machine learning engineer
is to train the best performing model
possible depending on the problem at
hand you will need to choose a suitable
error measure and an evaluation strategy
for a machine learning model
the most vulnerable part of a machine
learning candidate's resume is the
absence of experience working on diverse
machine learning projects with all the
essential skills acquired you can now
build an impressive machine learning
portfolio highlighting some exciting
machine learning projects
machine learning Engineers need a
portfolio that showcases their expertise
to implement machine learning techniques
to real-world problems with your resume
ready you can now look for the best
machine learning jobs in top product
companies and startups you can become a
machine learning engineer a data
scientist a data analyst or a research
scientist some of the top companies
hiring for machine learning roles are
Google Amazon IBM Uber graminer Nvidia
and Linkedin machine learning Engineers
are some of the highest paid
Professionals in the world according to
glassdoor.com the national average
salary for machine learning engineers in
the United States is 1 lakh 31 000 US
dollars per year in India you can earn
nearly 8 lakh rupees per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy there are
immense opportunities in machine
learning for sectors such as e-commerce
manufacturing Logistics retail and
Healthcare if you are interested in a
career in machine learning then start
your journey now with simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning that is in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM
you will learn all the in-demand machine
learning skills and work on programming
with Hands-On examples the program also
offers job assistance to know more about
the learning part tools covered and
projects that you'll be working on
please click on the course page Link in
the description below
in this video we will cover everything
you need to know to become an expert in
machine learning our experienced
instructors with good industry
experience will take you through this
course
first you will understand the basics of
machine learning from a short animated
video
you will then know the essential
applications of machine learning you
will understand machine learning
Concepts and Learn by mathematics
statistics and linear algebra are
crucial then we'll focus on some vital
machine learning algorithms such as
linear regression logistic regression
decision trees random forest and K
nearest Neighbors
you will also learn about regularization
dimensionality reduction and principal
component analysis we will perform a
prediction analysis on the recently held
U.S elections as well finally you will
study the machine learning roadmap for
2021 so let's begin
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and to what humans can do and much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's Paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
Paul decides this on the basis of the
song's Tempo genre intensity and the
gender of voice for Simplicity let's
just use Tempo and intensity for now so
here Tempo is on the x-axis ranging from
relaxed to fast whereas intensity is on
the y-axis ranging from light to Soaring
we see that Paul likes the song with
fast tempo and soaring intensity while
he dislikes the song with relaxed Tempo
and light intensity so now we know
Paul's choices let's say Paul listens to
a new song Let's name it as song a song
a has fast tempo and a soaring intensity
so it lies somewhere here looking at the
data can you guess whether Paul will
like the song or not correct so Paul
likes this song by looking at Paul's
past choices we were able to classify
the unknown song very easily right let's
say now Paul citizens to a new song
Let's label it as song b so song b lies
somewhere here with medium Tempo and
medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess where the ball likes it or not
not able to guess where this ball will
like it or dislike it other choices
unclear correct we could easily classify
song A but when the choice became
complicated as in the case of song b yes
and that's where machine learning comes
in let's see how in the same example for
song p if you draw a circle around the
song b we see that there are four words
for like whereas one vote for dislike if
we go for the majority votes we can say
that Paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called K
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
project for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you 1 million
coins of three different currencies say
one rupee one Euro and one dirham each
coin has different weights for example a
coin of one rupee weighs 3 grams one
Euro weighs 7 grams and one dirham
weighs 4 grams your model will predict
the currency of the coin here your
weight becomes the feature of coins
while currency becomes the label when
you feed this data to the machine
learning model it learns which feature
is associated with which sleep for
example it will learn that if a point is
of 3 grams it will be a one rupee coin
let's give a new coin to the machine on
the basis of the weight of the new coin
your model will predict the currency
hence supervised learning uses labeled
data to train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features on this note let's move to
unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have Cricut data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while it runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored High
runs and took less wickets while the
other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsman and Bowlers an important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsman and Bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unabled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward-based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns I hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario 1 Facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario 2 Netflix recommends new movies
based on someone's Past movie choices
scenario 3 analyzing Bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody's
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational Powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
Diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech Giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a cab you must have
encountered search pricing often where
it says the fare of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please I'm
getting late for office well that's an
interesting machine learning model which
is used by Global Taxi giant Uber and
others where they have differential
pricing in real time based on demand the
number of cars available bad weather
Rush R Etc so they use the search
pricing model to ensure that those who
need a cab can get one also it uses
predictive modeling to predict where the
demand will be high with a goal that
drivers can take care of the demand and
search pricing can be minimized great
hey Siri can you remind me to book a cab
at 6 pm today okay I'll remind you
thanks no problem comment below some
interesting everyday examples around you
where machines are learning and doing
amazing jobs so that's all for machine
learning Basics today from my site
machine learning has improved lives in a
number of wonderful ways today let's
talk about some of these I'm Rahul from
Simply learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistance Google Assistant Alexa
Cortana and Siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record what are
you saying send it over to a server
which is usually in a cloud decoded with
the help of machine learning in neural
networks and then provide you with an
output so if you've ever noticed that
these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say I
wanted to travel from Buckingham Palace
to Lord's cricket ground the first thing
I'd probably do is to get on Google Maps
so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they are slightly congested and red
means they're heavily congested so let's
look at the map a different version of
the same map and here as I told you
before red means heavily congested
yellow means slow moving and blue means
clear
so how exactly is Google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from Google
Maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
Bing Maps maps.me and here we go next up
we have social media personalization so
say I want to buy a drone and I'm on
Amazon and I want to buy a DJI mavic Pro
the thing is it's close to one lap so I
don't want to buy it right now but the
next time I'm on Facebook I'll see an
advertisement for the product next time
I'm on YouTube I'll see an advertisement
even on Instagram I'll see an
advertisement so here with the help of
machine learning Google has understood
that I'm interested in this particular
product hence it's targeting me with
these advertisements this is also with
the help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
Gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so Gmail has entire collection of emails
which have already been labeled as spam
or not spam so after analyzing this data
Gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that Gmail uses is content
filters header filters General Blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values Stock Market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to Stock
Market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long
short-term memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict data when there are time lags of
unknown size and duration now this is
used to predict stock market trends
assistive Medical Technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3D models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and Ice chemic stock lesions they
can also be used in fetal Imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug Discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in a foreign country and
you see Billboards and signs that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chatbots
here the image recognition happens using
convolutional neural networks and the
text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequential sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other hello and welcome
to machine learning tutorial part one
this is part one of a machine learning
series put on by simply learn my name is
Richard kirschner I'm with the simply
learned team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you today well
we'll start off with a brief explanation
of why machine learning and what is
machine learning and then we'll get into
a few of the types of machine learning
machine learning algorithms linear
regression decision trees support Vector
machine and finally we'll do a use case
where we're going to classify whether a
recipe is of a cupcake or a muffin using
the svm or the support Vector machine
sounds like a delicious way to explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with Google's
waymo and then Uber had their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
Transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now usually ticked over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that within
some areas where maybe not for eyes but
for other diseases where they're using
the camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go in and see
the doctor and because the machine can
now unlock your phone with your face I
mean this is cool having it being able
to identify your face or your voice and
be able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation or world we live in and as we
dig in deeper we have a nice example of
Facebook as you can see here they have
the Facebook post with Halloween comment
yes if you want it order here nobody
likes spam post on Facebook that annoy
them into interacting with likes shares
comments and other actions I remember
the original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of Fear Factor well this is a
huge thing in a social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of Facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
Engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using Facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools for
building and the Facebook scroll GIF
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain setup with Facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of General titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that Takes Over part of the Facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what Facebook did to eliminate this
is they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
Facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport in a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you time share come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyiness so now
you can just enjoy your Facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures when mine is family
certainly people like their cat pictures
too another good example is Google's
Deep Mind project alphago a computer
program that plays a board game go has
defeated the world's number one go
player and I hope I say his name right
key G the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three was on May 27 2017. so it
was just last year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world but they are
using games to learn how to get the
machine learning program to learn they
wanted to learn how to learn and that is
a huge step a lot of this is still in
its infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as I
referred to earlier the Uber cars they
lost their whole division because they
jumped ahead too fast so still at infant
stage but boy is this like the beginning
of just an amazing world that is
automated in ways we can't even imagine
what tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning so let's see if we can give a
little bit more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is a science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed we see here
we have a nice little diagram where we
have our ordinary system and your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of stuff on a cell phone because cell
phones advance so much and then with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns from what happened before and
then it predicts what's going to come
next and then really the biggest part
right now in machine learning that's
going on is it improves on that how do
we find a new solution so we go from
descriptive words learning about stuff
and understanding how it fits together
to predicting what it's going to do to
post scripting coming up with a new
solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diet grams that people have
posted for what steps to go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on Photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to The Domain this is kind of very
general diagram first you want to Define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches you spend a lot of time in data
science collecting data in The Next Step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in then you're going to
select the algorithm which algorithm are
you going to use you're going to train
that algorithm in this case I think
we're going to be working with svm the
support Vector machine then you have to
test the model does this mod will work
is this a valid model for what we're
doing and then once you've tested it and
you want to run your prediction you want
to run your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's going to come up
with and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
remember I said domain specific this is
very general as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey I'm not
really getting the answers I need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model it's a very
good model to start with and we do have
some basic divisions of what machine
learning does that's important to know
for instance do you want to predict a
category well if you're categorizing
thing that's classification for instance
whether the stock prices will increase
or decrease so in other words I'm
looking for a yes no answer is it going
up or is it going down and in that case
we'd actually say is a going up true if
it's not going up it's false meaning
it's going down this way it's a yes no 0
1. do you want to predict a quantity
that's regression so remember we just
did classification now we're looking at
regression these are the two major
divisions and what data is doing for
instance predicting the age of a person
based on the height weight health and
other factors So based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is and then there are a lot
of domain specific things like do you
want to detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm I'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being LD Tech
anomalies is very big in data science
these days another question that comes
up which is on what we call untrained
data is do you want to discover
structure in unexplored data and that's
called clustering for instance finding
groups of customers with similar
Behavior given a large database of
customer data containing their
demographic ethics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to Market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to Market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any Arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and Investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before we even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to Cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick DeTour for quiz time
oh my favorite so we're gonna have a
couple questions here under a quiz time
and we'll be posting the answers in
these part two of this tutorial so let's
go ahead and take a look at these quiz
times questions and hopefully you'll get
them all right it'll get you thinking
about how to process data and what's
going on can you tell what's happening
in the following cases of course you're
sitting there with your cup of coffee
and you have your checkbox and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis so
the first one is grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document very big
these days you know you have legal
documents you have maybe it's a Sports
Group documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world B
identifying handwritten digits and
images correctly so we want to know
whether they're writing an A or capital
A B C what are they writing out in their
hand their handwriting C behavior of a
website indicating that the site is not
working as designed D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience HR hiring uh set up
there so stay tuned for part two we'll
go ahead and answer these questions when
we get to the part two of this tutorial
or you can just simply write at the
bottom and send a note to Simply learn
and they'll follow up with you on it
back to our regular content
and these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jumble of data with
circles triangles and squares and then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square and we
have a model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because it's talking about Banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're going to make money or
not that's always important and if you
are looking to make a fortune in the
stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates in ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is or what a triangle is
and what a square is it goes in there
looks at him and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have have in
common maybe you have one of them who's
a customer at your store or you have
five of them or customer at your store
and they have a lot in common with five
others who are not customers at your
store how do you Market to those five
who aren't customers at your store yet
they fit the demographs of who's going
to shop there and you'd like them to
shop at your store and not the one next
door of course this is a simplified
version you can see very easily the
difference between a triangle and a
circle which might not be so easy in
marketing reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is an important
type of machine learning or an agent
learns how to behave in an environment
by performing actions and seeing the
result and we have here where the in
this case a baby it's actually great
that they used an infant for this slide
because the reinforcement learning is
very much in its infant stages but it's
also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforcement
learning and how to make that work for
us and you can see here where we have
our action in the action in this one it
goes into the fire hopefully the baby
didn't it was just a little candle not a
giant fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the new
state is the baby is sad and crying
because they got burned on the fire and
then maybe they take another action the
baby's called the agent because it's the
one taking the actions and in this case
they didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you know you bring
yourself on the stove don't do that
anymore don't touch the stove in the big
picture being able to have a machine
learning program under an AI be able to
do this is huge because now we're
starting to learn how to learn that's a
big jump in the world of computer and
machine learning and we're going to go
back and just kind of go back over
supervise versus unsupervised learning
understanding this is huge because this
is going to come up in any project
you're working on we have in supervised
learning we have labeled data we have
direct feedback so some one's already
gone in there and said yes that's a
triangle no that's not a triangle and
then you predict an outcome so you have
a nice prediction this is this this new
set of data is coming in and we know
what it's going to be and then with
unsupervised training it's not labeled
so we really don't know what it is
there's no feedback so we're not telling
it whether it's right or wrong we're not
telling it whether it's a triangle or a
square we're not telling it to go left
or right all we do is we're finding
hidden structure in the data grouping
the data together to find out what
connects to each other and then you can
use these together so imagine you have
an image and you're not sure what you're
looking for so you go in and you have
the unstructured data find all these
things that are connected together and
then somebody looks at those and labels
them now you can take that label data
and program something to predict what's
in the picture so you can see how they
go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algae algorithms let's have a look at a
few of them hopefully this give you a
little flavor of what's out there and
these are some of the most important
ones that are currently being used we'll
take a look at linear regression
decision tree and the support Vector
machine let's start with a closer look
at linear regression linear regression
is perhaps one of the most well-known
and well understood algorithms in
statistics and machine learning linear
regression is a linear model for example
a model that assumes a linear
relationship between the input variables
X and the single output variable Y and
you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals MX plus C
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed X our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times X plus
C or distance equals m times speed plus
C where m is the coefficient and C is
the y-intercept and we're going to look
at two different variations of this
first we're going to start with time is
and you can see we have a bicyclist he's
got a safety gear on thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers we have a
second bicyclist who's going twice the
speed or 20 meters per second and you
can guess if he's going twice the speed
and time is a constant then he's going
to go twice the distance and that's easy
to compute 36 times 2 you get 72
kilometers and so if you had the
question of how fast would somebody is
going three times that speed or 30
meters per second is you can easily
compute the distance in our head we can
do that without needing a computer but
we want to do this for more complicated
data so it's kind of nice to compare the
two but let's just take a look at that
and what that looks like in a graph so
in a linear regression model we have our
distance to the speed and we have our m
equals the ve slope of the line and
we'll notice that the line has a plus
slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive active
relationship and so your speed of the
person which equals y equals MX plus C
distance traveled in a fixed interval of
time and we could very easily compute
either following the line or just
knowing us three times ten meters per
second that this is roughly 102
kilometers distance to this third bicep
this has traveled one of the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so to
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second we have a certain
distance to go and it takes them 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess he'll
cover the distance in about half the
time 50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one 100
divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you could easily guess
that this is 33.333 seconds time we put
that into a a regression model or a
graph if the distance is soon to be
constant let's see the relationship
between speed and time and as time goes
up the amount of speed to go that same
distance goes down so now your m equals
a minus v e slope of the line as the
speed increases time decreases hence the
variable has a negative relationship
again there's our definition positive
relationship and negative relationship
dependent on the slope of the line and
with a simple formula like this and even
a significant amount of data let's see
what the mathematical implementation of
linear regression and we'll take this
data so suppose we have this data set
where we have x y x equals one two three
four five standard series and the Y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is as we come up here we
have the mean of x i and remember mean
is basically the average so we added
five plus four plus three plus two plus
one and divide by five and that simply
comes out as three and then we'll do the
same for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of I
equals 2.8 or the x i references it's an
average or means value and the Y I also
equals a means value of y and when we
plot that you'll see that we can put in
the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3 in
there on our graph and we kind of gave
it a little different color so you could
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot now let's find our regression
equation to find the best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals MX plus C so we're looking for M
and C so to find this equation for our
data we need to find our slope of M and
our coefficient of C and we have y
equals MX plus C where m equals the sum
of x minus X average times y minus y
average or y means and X means over the
sum of x minus X means squared that's
how we get the slope of the value of the
line and we can easily do that by
creating some columns here we have X Y
computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily compute this and fill in a graph
of data and in our graph you can easily
see that if we have our x value of 1 and
if you remember the x i or the means
value is three one minus 3 equals a
negative two and two minus three equals
a negative one so on and so forth and we
can easily fill in the column of x minus
x i y minus y i and then from those we
can compute x minus x i squared and x
minus x i times y minus y i and you can
guess it that the next step is to go
ahead and sum the different columns for
the answers we need
so we get a total of 10 for our x minus
x i squared and a total of 2 for x minus
x i times y minus y i and we plug those
in we get 2 10 which equals 0.2 so now
we know the slope of our line equals 0.2
so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y axis and if
you remember I mentioned earlier that
the linear regression line has to pass
through the means value the one that we
showed earlier we can just flip back up
there to that graph and you can see
right here there's our means value which
is three x equals 3 and Y equals 2.8 and
since we know that value we can simply
plug that into our formula y equals 0.2
X plus C so we plug that in we get 2.8
equals 0.2 times 3 plus C and you can
just solve for C so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times X
Plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of Y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the one two
three four five was our original X
values so now we're going to see what y
thinks they are not what they actually
are and we plug those in we get y of
designated with Y of P you can see that
x equals one equals 2.4 x equals 2
equals 2.6 and so on and so on so we
have our y predicted values of what we
think is going to be when we plug those
numbers in and when we plot the
predicted values along with the axial
values we can see the difference and
this is one of the things that's very
important with linear regression in any
of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted X and Y and
Y predict and we'd run a little line so
you can sort of see what the arrow looks
like there between the different points
so our goal is to reduce this error
error we want to minimize that error
value on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize the distance between
the line and the data points like sum of
squared errors sum of absolute errors
root mean square error Etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line has the
least squared distance between the data
points and the regression line so to
recap with a very simple linear
regression model we first figure out the
formula of our line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error keep in mind this is
a very simple formula the math gets even
though the math is very much the same it
gets much more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y equals MX plus C but you
can take that out to x z i j Q all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems than the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the Outlook whether it's a
rainy overcast Sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you can imagine
if you got up in the night before you're
trying to plan your day and it comes up
and says tomorrow would be a good day
for golf for you in the morning and not
a good day in the afternoon or something
like that this becomes very beneficial
and we see this in a lot of applications
coming out now where it gives you
suggestions and lets you know what would
fit the match for you for the next day
or the next purchase or the next
whatever you know next meal out in this
case is tomorrow a good day for playing
golf based on the weather coming in and
so we come up and let's determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the Outlook and if the Outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's rainy
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast and
you get just the right Shadow that's a
good day to play golf and be outside out
on the green now in this example you can
probably make your own tree pretty
easily because it's a very simple set of
data going in but the question is how do
you know what to split where do you
split your data what if this is much
more complicated data where it's not
something that you would particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous cells and then each one of
those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but so that's the question that's
going to come up is this the right
decision tree for that we should
calculate entropy and Information Gain
to important vocabulary words there are
the entropy and the Information Gain
entropy entropy is a measure of
Randomness or impurity in the data set
entropy should be low so we want the
chaos to be as low as possible we don't
want to look at it and be confused by
the images or what's going on there with
mixed data and the Information Gain it
is a measure of decrease in entropy
after the data set is split also known
as entropy reduction information gains
should be high so we want our
information that we get out of the split
to be as high as possible let's take a
look at entropy from the mathematical
side in this case we're going to denote
entropy as I of P of n n where p is the
probability that you're going to play a
game of golf and N is the probability
where you're not going to play the game
of golf now you don't really have to
memorize these formulas there's a few of
them out there depending on what you're
working with but it's important to note
that this is where this formula is
coming from so when you see it you're
not lost when you're running your
programming unless you're building your
own decision tree code in the back and
we simply have a log squared of p over P
plus n minus M over P plus n times the
log squared of n of p plus n but let's
break that down and see what actually
looks like when we're Computing that
from the computer script side entropy of
a target class of the data set is the
whole entropy so we have entropy play
golf and we look at this if we go back
to the data you can simply count how
many yeses and no in our complete data
set for playing golf days in our
complete set we find we have five days
we did play golf and nine days we did
not play golf and so our I equals if you
have those together nine plus five is
14. and so our I equals 5 over 14 and 9
over 14. that's our p and N values and
we plug into that formula and you can go
with 5 over 4T equals 0.36 9 over 14
equals 0.64 and when you do the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36 log root
squared of 0.36 minus 0.64 log square
root of 0.64 and we get a set value we
get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the Outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
Sunny Times e of 3 of 2 and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is 5. don't forget but we'll
divide that five out later on equals P
overcast equals 4 comma 0 plus rainy
equals two comma three and then when you
do the whole setup we have 5 over 14.
remember I said there was a total of
five five over fourteen times the I of
three of two plus four over fourteen
times the four comma zero and five
fourteen over I of two three and so we
can now compute the entropy of just the
part it has to do with the forecast and
we get 0.693 similarly we can calculate
the entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain Outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf Outlook and
we can take the original 0.94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
rainy day in temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247 so this is our
Information Gain remember we Define
entropy and we Define an information
gain the higher the information gain the
lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029 we have our gain for
humidity equals 0.152 and our gain for a
windy day equals 0.048 and if you do a
quick comparison you'll see the 0.247 is
the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the Outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
Information Gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest Information
Gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
Information Gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see that
it's a very easy to view visual model we
have our Outlook we split it three
different directions if the Outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the Outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go Outlook Sunny Outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says I'm
sorry tomorrow's not a good day for golf
it's going to be sunny and windy and if
you're a huge golf fan you might go uh
oh it's not a good day to play golf we
can go in and watch a golf game at home
so we'll sit in front of the TV instead
of being out playing golf in the wind
now that we looked at our decision tree
let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
Vector machine support Vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the ideas support Vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females a new data point arrives and
we want to know whether it's going to be
a male or a female so we start by
drawing a line we draw decision lines
but if we consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a male and if we consider decision line
two then it will be a female so you can
see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups so it's a
little confusing trying to figure out
which line they should be under we need
to know which line divides the classes
correctly but how the goal is to choose
a hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support Vector machines choose a
hyperplane with the greatest possible
margin between the decision line and the
nearest Point within the training set so
you can see here we have our support
Vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equal the distance between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line 1 has a max from
distance margins so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is Mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line is
that a lot of times we're not looking at
just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyper plane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example problem statement I
always start with a problem statement
when you're going to put some code
together we're going to do some coding
now classifying muffin and cupcake
recipes using support Vector machines so
the cupcake versus the muffin let's have
a look at our data set and we have the
different recipes here we have a muffin
recipe that has so much flour I'm not
sure what measurement 55 is in but it
has 55 maybe it's ounces but a certain
amount of flour certain amount of milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt and So based on these
measurements we want to guess whether
we're making a muffin or a cupcake and
you can see in this one we don't have
just two features we don't just have
height and weight as we did before
between the male and female in here we
have a number of features in fact in
this we're looking at eight different
features to guess whether it's a muffin
or a cupcake what's the difference
between a muffin and a cupcake turns out
muffins have more flour while cupcakes
have more butter and sugar so basically
the cupcakes a little bit more of a
dessert where the muffins a little bit
more of a fancy bread but how do we do
that in Python how do we code that to go
through recipes and figure out what the
recipe is and I really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
started in our cupcakes versus muffins
we are going to be working in Python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda in Jupiter nopa the
Anaconda Navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the Anaconda
Navigator you can change environments I
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using Python 3 6
environment so this is in Python version
three six although it doesn't matter too
much which version you use I usually try
to stay with the 3x because they're
current unless you have a project that's
very specifically in version 2x 2 7 I
think is usually what most people use in
the version two and then once we're in
our Jupiter notebook editor I can go up
and create a new file and we'll just
jump in here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus Cupcake and then let's start with
our packages for data analysis
and we almost always use a couple
there's a few very standard packages we
use
we use import oops import import import
numpy
that's for number python this usually
denoted as NP that's very comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
PD
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy setup as far as
multiplying all the values in an array
in an empty array data array
pandas I can't remember if we're using
it actually in this data set I think we
do as an import it makes a nice data
frame and the difference between a data
frame and a numpy array is it a data
frame it's more like your Excel
spreadsheet you have columns you have
indexes so you have different ways of
referencing it easily viewing it and
there's additional features you can run
on a data frame and pandas kind of sits
on numpy so that you need them both in
there
and then finally we're working with the
support Vector machine so from SK learn
we're going to use the sklearn model
import svm support Vector machine
and then
as a data scientist you should always
try to visualize your data some data
obviously is too complicated or doesn't
make any sense to the human but if it's
possible it's going to take a second
look at it so that you can actually see
what you're doing now for that we're
going to use two packages we're going to
import
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT again very
common
and we're going to import Seaborn as SNS
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the SNS right in our import
line that's what this semicolon followed
by a line of data we're going to set the
SNS and these are great because the the
Seaborn sits on top of matplot Library
just like pandas hits on numpy so it
adds a lot more features and uses and
control we're obviously not going to get
into matplot library in Seabourn it'd be
its own tutorial we're really just
focusing on the svm the support Vector
machine from sklearn and since we're in
Jupiter notebook we have to add a
special line in here for our matplot
library and that's your percentage sign
or Amber sign matplot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code Project A lot of times I
use like notepad plus plus and I'll
write it from there you don't have to
have that line in there because it'll
just pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your computer
is set
because we're writing this in the
Jupiter notebook as a browser setup this
tells it to display all of our Graphics
right below on the page so that's what
that line is for remember the first time
I ran this I didn't know that and I had
to go look that up years ago that was
quite a headache so matplot Library
inline is just because we're running
this on the web setup and we can go
ahead and run this make sure all our
modules are in they're all imported
which is great if you don't have them
import you'll need to go ahead and pip
use the PIP or however you do it there's
a lot of other install packages out
there although pip is the most common
and you have to make sure these are all
installed on your python setup the next
step of course is we got to look at the
data you can't run a model for
predicting data if you don't have actual
data so to do that let me go ahead and
open this up and take a look and we have
our cupcakes versus muffins and it's a
CSV file or dot CSV meaning that it's
comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
CSV remember as a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops I got
double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program I loaded or the the
place I saved this particular Python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on there
and then because we're in pandas we're
going to go ahead and we can actually in
line you can do this but let me do the
full print you can just type in recipes
dot head
in the Jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you'd need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and Panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five lines of data and if we
flip back out over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our CSV file
uh you can see where it starts on line
two this one calls it zero and then two
three four five six is going to match go
and close that out so we don't need that
anymore and it always starts at zero and
these are it automatically indexes it
since we didn't tell it to use an index
in here so that's the index number for
the left hand side and it automatically
took the top row as labels so pandas
using it to read a CSV is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas not just because they're
cute and cuddly teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data and
I'm not going to plot all of it I'm just
going to plot the sugar and flour
now obviously you can see where they get
really complicated if we have tons of
different features and so you'll break
them up and maybe look at just two of
them at a time to see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use Seaborn
so that's our SNS and the command for
that is
sns.lmplot and then the two different
variables I'm going to plot is flour and
sugar
data equals recipes
the Hue equals type and this is a lot of
fun because it knows that this is pandas
coming in so this is one of the powerful
things about pandas mixed with Seabourn
in doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
Seabourn or do a regular regular equals
false so we're not really trying to fit
anything and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in Seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a Seaborn plot
let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone there's a
definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at it and say hey if I
drew a line right between the middle of
the blue dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a
hyperplane right there in the middle
then the next step is to format or pre
process our data
and we're going to break that up into
two parts
we need to type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake well
a computer doesn't know muffin or
cupcake at no zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and P where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our Panda and
wherever a type equals muffin is going
to be zero and then if it doesn't equal
muffin which is cupcakes it's going to
be one so we create our type label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's zero
or one it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the First Column is type
so we really don't need the type columns
that's our muffin or cupcake and in
pandas we can easily sort that out
we take our value recipes
dot columns that's a panda's function
built into pandas
we've got values so converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is it always
starts at zero we want one
colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and I forgot the S on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg baking powder
vanilla and salt and that matches what
we have up here right where we printed
out everything but the type so we have
our features and we have our label
Now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns we actually need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're dealing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients we
have you know that's what
um
seven eight different hyper planes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values we don't need to make a list out
of it because it's not string values
these are actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just another flour and
sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and take our recipe
features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values but because we want
to be able to view this easily in a plot
later on we'll go ahead and take that
and just do flour and sugar
and we'll run that and you'll see it's
just the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called SVC
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the svm
you'll see that there's about there's
eight of them here three of them are for
regression
three or four classification the SVC
support Vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers and another one that has to do
with something a bit more specific on
the model but SBC and SBR are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support Vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or whatever
you're trying to work on and SBC is a
classifier so it's a yes no true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
if we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
going to do model dot fit and this is
very common especially in the sklearn
all their models are followed with the
fit command
and what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients which in this case we
limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into uh
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things that go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and I got an error here so let me fix
that real quick it's Capital SBC it
turns out
I did it lower case
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically these are the defaults of
the model you notice that we change the
kernel to linear and there's our kernel
linear on the printout and there's other
different settings you can mess with
we're going to just to leave that alone
for right now for this we don't really
need to mess with any of those
next
dig a little bit into our newly trained
model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a graph
and let's go ahead and get the
separating
and we're going to say we're going to
use a W for our variable on here
we're going to do model dot coefficient
underscore zero so what the heck is that
again we're digging into the model so
we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now
and so
the W is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals MX plus C so
these coefficients are connected to that
but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't want to spend too much time on
this because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math so if you're a
math whiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
a equals minus W of 0 over W of one
remember there's two different values
there and that's basically the slope
that we're generating
and then we're going to build an XX what
is XX we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our NP dot line
space so we're creating a line
plus The Intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y equals the
slope times each value in that array
that's a neat thing about numpy so when
I do a times XX which is a whole lumpy
array of values it multiplies a across
all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept that's
here uh remember we had MX plus C so
that'd be the C from the formula y
equals MX plus c
and that's where all these numbers come
from a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that pass through the support
vectors and so we're going to create b
equals a model support vectors pulling
our support vectors out there here's our
YY which we now know is a set of data we
have we're going to create YY down
equals a times XX plus B1 minus a times
B 0 and then model support Vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus one set up and YY up equals a
times XX plus B1 minus a times b0
and we can go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you want to
know understand a little bit more of
what's going on you can see if we print
YY let me just run that you can see it's
an array this is a line it's going to
have in this case between 30 and 60 so
it's going to be 30 variables in here
and the same thing with YY up YY down
and we'll we'll plot those in just a
minute on a graph so you can see what
those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
I'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our
sns.rcboard plot LM plot flower sugar
and I'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the neat things is
because Seaborn sits on top of Pi plot
we can do the pi plot for the line going
through and that is simply PLT Dot Plot
and that's our XX
and YY are two corresponding values x y
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals 2
and the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pi plot on there and you
can see when we do this it's just doing
flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flower and the muffin versus Cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the YY down and YY out so let's
take a look and see what that looks like
so we'll do our PL plot
and again this is all against XX the our
x value but this time we have YY
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this we can put in a k Dash Dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line
and if we're going to do the down one
we also want to do the up one
so here's our YY
up and when we run that it adds both
sets of line
and so here's our support and this is
what you'd expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dashed lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
I've got my recipes I pulled off the um
internet and I want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through and create
a function with depth
and let's call it muffin or cupcake and
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients you know it's flour
and sugar
let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero so we
take our model and we do it run a
predict that's very common in SK learn
we have a DOT predict you put the data
in and it's going to return a value in
this case if it equals zero then print
you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for
function or def for definition d e f is
how you do that in Python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or cupcake I don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us and it says oh it's a muffin
you're looking at a muffin recipe
so it very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's plot this oops there we go plot
this on the graph so we can see where
that actually looks like
and I'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if I run it you'll see it has all
the points and the lines on there and
what we want to do is we want to add
another point
and we'll do PLT plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do y o for yellow or it's
kind of an oranges yellow color is going
to come out marker size nine those are
settings you can play with somebody else
played with them to come up with the
right setup so it looks good and you can
see there it is graph clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won and if you'd like to
do your own muffin cupcake Contender
series you certainly can send a note
down below and the team at simply learn
will send you over the data they use for
the muffin and cupcake and that's true
of any of the data we didn't actually
run a plot on it earlier we had men
versus women you can also request that
information to run it on your data setup
so you can test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support Vector machine
code we did a predict 40 Parts flower 20
Parts sugar I think it was different
than the one we did whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake hence we have built
a classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover k-means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial what's in it for you
we're going to cover clustering what is
clustering K means clustering which is
one of the most common used clustering
tools out there including a flowchart to
understand K means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on Brands then we're going to
cover logistic regression what is
logistic regression logistic regression
curve and sigmoid function and then
we'll do another python code demo to
classify a tumor as malignant or B9
based on features and let's start with
clustering suppose we have a pile of
books of different genres now we divide
them into different groups like fiction
horror education and as we can see from
this young lady she definitely is into
heavy you can just tell by those
eyes and the maple Canadian leaf on her
shirt but we have fiction horror and
education we want to go ahead and divide
our books up well organizing objects
into groups based on similarity is
clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the books we're talking about
clustering things with known categories
but you can also use it to explore data
so you might not know the categories you
just know that you need to divide it up
in some way to conquer the data and
organize it better but in this case
we're going to be looking at clustering
in specific categories and let's just
take a deeper look at that we're going
to use K means clustering K means
clustering is probably the most commonly
used clustering tool in the machine
learning library K means clustering is
an example of unsupervised learning if
you remember from our previous thing it
is used when you have unlabeled data so
we don't know the answer yet we have a
bunch of data that we want to Cluster to
different groups to find clusters in the
data based on feature similarity so
we've introduced a couple terms here
we've already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also in a introduced feature
similarity features being different
features of the data now with books we
can easily see fiction and horror and
history books but a lot of times with
data some of that information isn't so
easy to see right when we first look at
it and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect that match with each other
suppose we have these data points and
want to assign them into a cluster now
when I look at these data points I would
probably group them into two clusters
just by looking at them I'd say two of
these group of data kind of come
together but in K means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters inside random centroids to the
Clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances and
calculate the centroids so we figure out
what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those senses repeat previous
two steps iteratively till the cluster
centroid stop changing their positions
and become Static repeat previous two
steps iteratively to the cluster
centroid stop changing and the positions
become Static once the Clusters become
Static then K means clustering algorithm
is said to be converged and there's
another term we see throughout machine
learning is converged that means
whatever math we're using to figure out
the answer has come to a solution or
it's converged on an answer so we see
the flowchart to understand make a
little bit more sense by putting it into
a nice easy step-by-step so we start we
choose K we'll look at the elbow method
in just a moment we assign random
centroids to clusters and sometimes you
pick the centroids because you might
look at the data in a graph and say oh
these are probably the central points
then we compute the distance from the
objects to the centroids we take that
and we form new clusters based on
minimum distance and calculate their
centroids then we compute the distance
from object to the new centroids and
then we go back and repeat those last
two steps we calculate the distances so
as we're doing it brings into the new
centroid and then we move the centroid
around and we figure out what the best
which objects are closest to each
centroid so the objects can switch from
one centroid to the other the centroids
are moved around and we continue that
until it is converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics A and B so
here's our subject in this case
referring to the person taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject B and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measured each
of those distances and you'd use the the
Pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the X and the
Y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster the centroid then
moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3 so
remember it was at one and one well the
very center of the data we're looking at
would put it at the one point roughly 2
2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the second one if
we wanted to make the overall mean
Vector the average Vector of all the
different distances to that centroid we
come up with four comma 1 and 5 4. so
we've now moved the centroids We compare
each individual's distance to its own
cluster mean and to that of the opposite
cluster and we find we can build a nice
chart on here that the as we move that
centroid around we now have a new
different kind of clustering of groups
and using euclidean distance between the
points and the mean we get the same
formula you see as new formulas coming
up so we have our individual dots
distance to the mean centrally to the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster only individual
three is narrowed to the mean of the
opposite cluster cluster 2 then its own
cluster one and you can see here in the
diagram where we've kind of circled that
one in the middle so when we've moved
the cluster the centroids of the
Clusters over one of the points shifted
to the other cluster because it's closer
to that group of individuals thus
individual 3 is relocate to Cluster 2
resulting in a new Partition and we
regenerate all those numbers of how
close they are to the different clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember I
brought up a concept earlier caming on
the k-means algorithm choosing the right
value of K will help in lesson number of
iterations and to find the appropriate
number of clusters in a data set we use
the elbow method and within sum of
squares WSS is defined as the sum of the
squared distance between each member of
the cluster in its centroid and so you
see we've done here is we have the
number of clusters and as you do the
same K means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate the
that centroid looks like and you find
the optimal you can actually find the
optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed at two
just by looking at the data but as you
can see the slope you actually just look
for right there where the elbow is in
the slope and you have a clear answer
that we want two different to start with
k means equals two a lot of times people
end up Computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain I
mentioned that last time you'll know
that that where to pick those numbers
and where to start guessing at what that
K value is so let's take this and we're
going to use a use case using K means
clustering to Cluster cars into Brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches make year Etc so we're
going to use the data set cars data
having information about three brands of
cars Toyota Honda and Nissan we'll go
back to my favorite tool the Anaconda
Navigator with the Jupiter notebook and
let's go ahead and flip over to our
jupyter notebook and in our jupyter
notebook I'm going to go ahead and just
paste the basic code that we usually
start a lot of these off with we're not
going to go too much into this code
because we've already discussed numpy
we've already discussed matplot library
and pandas that'll be being the number
array pandas being the pandas data frame
and matplot for the graphing and don't
forget since if you're using the jupyter
notebook you do need the matplot library
in line so that it plots everything on
the screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a pop-up
window on your computer and we'll go
ahead and run this just to load our
libraries and our setup into here the
next step is of course to look at our
data which I've already opened up in a
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
the miles per gallon cylinders cubic
inches horsepower weight pounds how
heavy it is time it takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand Toyota Honda
Nissan so the different cars are coming
from all the way from 1971 if we scroll
down to uh the 80s we have between the
70s and 80s the number of cars that
they've put out and let's uh we come
back here we're gonna do importing the
data so we'll go ahead and do data set
equals and we'll use pandas to read this
in and it's uh from a CSV file remember
you can always post this in the comments
and request the data files for these
either in the comments here on the
YouTube video or go to simplylearn.com
and request that the car CSV I put it in
the same folder as the code that I've
stored so my python code is stored in
the same folder so I don't have to put
the full path if you store them in
different folders you do have to change
this and double check your name
variables and we'll go ahead and run
this and we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because it's a data set
we're importing and we've now imported
our car CSV into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the X data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple Loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
for i n x dot columns so we're going to
go through each of the columns and a lot
of times it's important I'll make lists
of the columns and do this because I
might remove certain columns or there
might be columns that I want to be
processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take X of I and we want
to go fill in a and that's a pandas
command but the question is what are we
going to fill the missing data with we
definitely don't want to just put in a
number that doesn't actually mean
something and so one of the tricks you
can do with this is we can take X of I
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into an integer
because a lot of these are integers so
we'll go ahead and keep it integers and
let me add the bracket here a lot of
editors will do this they'll think that
you're closing one bracket make sure you
get that second bracket in there if it's
a double bracket that's always something
that happens regularly so once we have
our integer of X of Y this is going to
fill in any missing data with the
average and I was so busy closing one
set of brackets I forgot that the mean
is also has brackets in there for the
pandas so we can see here we're going to
fill in all the data with the average
value for that column so if there's
missing data it's in the average of the
data it does have then once we've done
that we'll go ahead and loop through it
again
and just check and see to make sure
everything is filled in correctly and it
will print and then we take X is null
and this returns a set of the null
Valley or the how many lines are null
and we'll just sum that up to see what
that looks like and so when I run this
and so with the X what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because it had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the X out for one we could take the X
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the I location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows and all but the last column of
the data set and at this time we could
do values we just convert it to values
so that's one way to do this and if I
let me just put this down here and print
X
capital x we chose and I run this you
can see it's just the values we could
also take out the values and it's not
going to return anything because there's
no values connected to it what I like to
do with this is instead of doing the I
location which does integers more common
is to come in here and we have our data
set and we're going to do data set dot
or dataset dot columns and remember that
lists all the columns so if I come in
here
let me just Mark that as red and I print
data set dot columns
you can see that I have my index here I
have my MPG cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data Columns of Everything But
the last one minus one so now if I print
this you'll see the brand disappears and
so I can actually just take data set
columns minus one
and I'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's unmark this
and unmark this
and now if I do an x dot head I now have
a new data frame and you can see right
here we have all the different columns
except for the brand at the end of the
year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must have
been recorded as strings so we have a
neat feature in here on pandas to
convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric equals true and yes I
did have to go look that up I don't have
it memorized the convert numeric in
there if I'm working with a lot of these
things I remember them but um depending
on where I'm at what I'm doing I usually
have to look it up and we run that oops
I must have missed something in here let
me double check my spelling and when I
double check my spelling you'll see I
missed the first underscore in the
convert objects when I run this it now
has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values most people when they're doing
small amounts you're working with small
data pools discover afterwards that they
have a null value and they have to go
back and do this so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it and that's
fine that's just part of exploring the
data and understanding what you have
and I should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
X of I and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it and so with this
we want to go ahead and fill in X of I
pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
I'll put my brackets up and there's a
lot of different ways to fill this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
they and then look at it later in a
separate exploration of data one of the
tricks we can do is we can take our
column and we can find the means
and the means is in other or quotation
marks that's when we take the columns
we're going to fill in the non-existing
one with the means the problem is that
returns a decimal float so some of these
aren't decimals certainly let me be a
little careful of doing this but for
this example we're just going to fill it
in with the integer version of this
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check ways you can do
that is simply go in here
and take our X of I column so it's going
to go through the x of I column it says
is null so it's going to return any any
place there's a null value it actually
goes through all the rows of each column
is null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that we add the sum
value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that and we go
ahead and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric and we've removed the last
column in our data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters so we're
now actually getting into the sklearn
part the K means clustering on here
well I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more not so you can see what I'm
typing in here
and then from sklearn I'm going to R or
sklearn
cluster
we're going to import k
means
I always forget to capitalize the K and
the M when I do this so it's capital K
capital M K means
and we'll go and create a array wcss
equals let me get an empty array if you
remember from the elbow method from our
slide
within the sums of squares WSS is
defined as the sum of squared distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a
squared distance and we're going to run
this over a number of K mean values
in fact let's go for I in range we'll do
11 of them
we're in 0 of 11.
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual we'll
do it all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the K mean so we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters and we're going to set that
equals to I that's the most important
one because we're looking at how
increasing the number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the K means our guys in the
back did a great job just kind of
playing with some of them the most
common ones that you see in a lot of
stuff is how you admit your k-means so
we have K means plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a Max
iteration we put in there
we have a the infinite the random State
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals I so we're going to literally
train our K means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times and if
you're working with big data you know
the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if I'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the SK learn
very common that you fit your model if
you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x and once we
fit this value we go back to the array
we made and we want to go and just
depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so K means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our PLT plot and what we're plotting
here
is first the x-axis which is range 0 11
so that will generate a nice little plot
there and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do PLT
X label
what we'll do we'll do number of
clusters for that and PLT y label
and for that we can do oops
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply PLT dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully I didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at 2 and again right around three
and four and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if I was looking
at this I would do either three or four
and I'd actually try both of them to see
what the output looked like and they've
already tried this in the back so we're
just going to use three as a setup on
here and let's go ahead and see what
that looks like when we actually use
this to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the car's data set and
basically we're going to copy the code
that we looped through up above where K
means equals K means number of clusters
and we're just going to set the number
of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do three and four on
this and graph them just to see how they
come up differently be kind of curious
to look at that but for this we're just
going to set it to three go ahead and
create our own variable y k means for
our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops that double equal there 2K means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different because usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the K means
on this and that's fit underscore
predict and then our capital x is the
data we're working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set X as Matrix so we're converting this
into a nice rows and columns kind of set
up but we want the we're going to have
columns equals none so it's just going
to be a matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see those
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of Matrix now that's
more common to set it dot values instead
of doing as Matrix but Mass Matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data I always like to take a look and
see what I am plotting so let's take a
look at why K means I'm just going to
print that out down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2 so it's clustering
these different rows of data based on
the three different spaces it thinks
it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print X and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that X is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or at position
0 and 1.
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting you might actually do a little
different than and dig a little deeper
into the different aspects because this
is all the different columns we looked
at but when we look at columns one and
two for this to make it easy so let's go
ahead and clear this data out of here
and let's bring up our plot and we're
going to do a scatter plot here so PLT
scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the X values
and we're only interested in y of K
means equals zero the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the X axes and then we're going to do
the same thing here we're only
interested in K means equals zero but
we're going to take this second column
so we're looking at the first two
columns in our answer or in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
if it has a size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots we're going to use red
for this one and when they were looking
at the data and what came out it was
definitely the Toyota on this we're just
going to go ahead and label it Toyota
again that's something you really have
to explore in here as far as playing
with those numbers and see what looks
good we'll go ahead and hit enter in
there and I'm just going to paste in the
next two lines which is the next two
cars
and this is our Nissa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where y underscore K
means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns 0 and 1 and
each of these rows then corresponds to
Nissan and Honda
and I'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our K means the model we
created dot cluster centers and we're
going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with zero and
one
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title PLT
title
and pop up there PLT title because you
always want to make your graphs look
pretty and we'll call it clusters of car
make
and one of the features of the plot
library is you can add a
Legend it'll automatically bring in it
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
Toyota Nissan and Honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's in line so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupyter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this and
we have a clusters of Honda and green
Toyota and red Nissan and purple and you
can see where they put the centroids to
separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
car making we were able to pull out the
data and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different almost going in
reverse you start looking at the data
and pulling apart the columns to find
out why is the first group set up the
way it is maybe you're doing loans and
you want to go well why is this group
not defaulting on their loans and why is
the last group defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group fifty
percent defaulting on their bank loans
and you start finding ways to manipulate
the data and pull out the answers you
want
me
so now that you've seen how to use K
mean for clustering let's move on to the
next topic now let's look into logistic
regression the logistic regression
algorithm is the simplest classification
algorithm used for binary or
multi-classification problems and we can
see we have our little girl from Canada
who's into horror books is back that's
actually really scary when you think
about that with those big eyes in the
previous tutorial we learned about
linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush up y
equals MX plus C very basic algebraic
function of Y and X the dependent
variable is the target class variable we
are going to predict
the independent variables X1 all the way
up to X in are the features or
attributes we're going to use to predict
the target class we know what a linear
regression looks like but using the
graph we cannot divide the outcome into
categories it's really hard to
categorize 1.5
3.6 9.8 for example a linear regression
graph can tell us that with increase in
number of hours studied the marks of a
student will increase but it will not
tell us whether the student will pass or
not in such cases where we need the
output as categorical value we will use
logistic regression and for that we're
going to use the sigmoid function so you
can see here we have our marks 0 to 100
number of hours studied that's going to
be what they're comparing it to in this
example and we usually form a line that
says y equals MX plus C and when we use
the sigmoid function we have P equals 1
over 1 plus e to the minus y it
generates a sigmoid curve curve and so
you can see right here when you take the
Ln which is the natural logarithm I
always thought it should be in L not Ln
that's just the inverse of e or e to the
minus y and so we do this we get Ln of p
over 1 minus P equals m times X plus C
that's the sigmoid curve function we're
looking for
we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1 or to zero depending
on what your x value is and the
probability if it's greater than 0.5 the
value is automatically rounded off to 1
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0.5 it
automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers or
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately I have to study hard to
learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or B9 and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but I also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if I told you that my
probability was really good it
classified things that say 90 or 95
percent and I'm classifying whether
you're going to have a malignant or a
benign tumor I'm guessing that you're
going to go get it tested anyways so you
got to remember the domain we're working
with so why would you want to do that if
you know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because you know it's that
serious this is like an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor know
where to look just by understanding what
kind of tumor it is so it might help
them or Aid them in something they
missed from before so let's go ahead and
dive into the code and I'll come back to
the domain part of it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal Imports here where we're
importing numpy pandas Seaborn the
matplat library and we're going to do
matplot library in line since I'm going
to switch over to Anaconda so let's go
ahead and flip over there and get this
started
so I've opened up a new window in my
anaconda Jupiter notebook
and by the way Jupiter notebook you
don't have to use Anaconda for the
Jupiter notebook I just love the
interface and all the tools that
Anaconda brings so we got our import
numpy as in P for our numpy number array
we have our pandas PD we're going to
bring in Seaborn to help us with the
graphs as SNS so many really nice Tools
in both Seabourn and matplot library and
we'll do our matplot library.pi plot as
PLT and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
creative today equals PD and this
happens to be in a CSV file
so we'll use a PD dot read underscore
CSV and I happen to name the file I
renamed it data for
p2.csv you can of course write in the
comments below the YouTube and request
for the data set itself or go to the
simply learn website and we'll be happy
to supply that for you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when I pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a CSV file
comma separated variables we have an ID
so I guess the categorizes for reference
or what id which test was done the
diagnosis M for malignant B for B9 so
there's two different options on there
and that's what we're going to try to
predict is the m and b and test it and
then we have like the radius mean or
average the texture average perimeter
mean area mean smoothness I don't know
about you but unless you're a doctor in
the field most of the stuff I mean you
can guess what concave means just by the
term concave if I really wouldn't know
what that means and the measurements are
taking so they have all kinds of stuff
like how smooth it is the Symmetry and
these are all float values we just page
through them real quick and you'll see
there's I believe 36 if I remember
correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth so back in our data and
I put this in the same folder as a code
so I saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have it in a different
location you want to put the full path
in there and we'll just do uh pandas
first five lines of data with the
data.head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an ID we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
Seaborn which we referenced as S and S
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice a very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the plot Library so the joint plot
does a lot of work for us and we're just
going to look at the first two columns
that we're interested in the radius mean
and the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting and
then we're going to use the data that we
pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at I mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commonest radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the on each
growth it's average texture and on each
radius it's average radius on there it
gets a little confusing because we're
talking about the individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the the histogram showing
us the median or how common each
measurement is and that's only two
columns so let's dig a little deeper
into Seabourn they also have a heat map
and if you're not familiar with heat
Maps a heat map just means it's in color
that's all that means heat map I guess
the original ones were plotting heat
density on something and so ever since
then it's just called a heat map and
we're going to take our data and get our
corresponding numbers to put that into
the heat map and that's simply
data.c-o-r-r for that that's a pandas
expression let's remember we're working
in a pandas data frame so that's one of
the Cool Tools in pandas for our data
and this is pull that information into a
heat map and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
ID we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle of this chart
diagonal going from the upper left to
bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence and you'll see that when
you look at say area or right below it
it has almost a black on there when you
compare it to texture so these have
almost no corresponding data They Don't
Really form a linear graph or something
that you can look at and say how
connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice graph to get a quick look at
your data doesn't so much change what
you do but it changes verifying so when
you get an answer or something like that
or you start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here I mean we can see
from the ID
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be B9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to ID this whether it's
malignant or B9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay we can't
solve this with any one feature it's
going to be something that includes all
the features or many of the different
features to come up with the solution
for it and while we're exploring the
data let's explore one more area and
let's look at data dot is null we want
to check for null values in our data if
you remember from earlier in this
tutorial we did it a little differently
where we added stuff up and sum them up
you can actually with pandas do it
really quickly data.is null and Summit
and it's going to go across all the
columns so when I run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no null data
so we've just just to rehash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seeing how they plot with the
Seaborn with a joint plot which shows
both the histogram and the data plotted
on the X Y coordinates and obviously you
can do that more in detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the Seabourn
heat map the
sns.heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on if you forget to do this step
it will remind you when you get that
nice error code that says null values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but it's no fun having to go back when
you're when you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you gotta go remember
where you were pulling the data in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
X and our y so we just put that down
here and we'll set the x equal to and
there's a lot of different options here
certainly we could do x equals all the
columns except for the first two because
if you remember the first two is the ID
in the diagnosis so that certainly would
be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up when you're looking at this
information
is sometimes the data will be the same
data coming in so if I have two
measurements coming into my model it
might overweigh them it might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measure it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
that we are dividing the data up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the worst so I'm going to create a an
array and you'll see this array radius
worst texture worst perimeter worst
we've just taken the worst of the worst
and I'm just going to put that in my X
so this x is still a pandas data frame
but it's just those columns and our y if
you remember correctly is going to be
oops hold on one second it's not X it's
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our Y for the stuff
we know and if you remember correctly
we're just going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it B9 or
malignant and since it's a single column
we can just do diagnosis oh I forgot to
put the brackets or the there we go okay
so it's just diagnosis on there and we
can also real quickly do like x dot head
if you want to see what that looks like
and Y dot head
and run this
and you'll see it only does the last one
I forgot about that if you don't do
print you can see that the the Y dot
head is just Mmm because the first ones
are all malignant and if I run this the
x dot head is just the first five values
of radius worst texture worst parameter
worst area worst and so on
I'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down to the next step we've
built our two data sets our answer and
then the features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn Models selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this I
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example is it necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables capital x train capital X test
so we have our training data we're going
to use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to trade the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do X and our y our
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random State it's always nice to
kind of switch your random State around
but not that important what this means
is that the test size is we're going to
take 30 percent of the data and we're
going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our X test and
we're going to do 70 into the X train
and the Y train so we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and
thirty percent to test it let's go ahead
and run that and load those up so now we
have all our stuff split up and all our
data ready to go and now we get to the
actual Logistics part we're actually
going to do our create our model so
let's go ahead and bring that in from
sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to import
logistic regression that's the actual
model we're using and this will call it
log model
oops there we go model and let's just
set this equal to our logistic
regression that we just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the models and the sklearn
we just need to go ahead and fix it fit
do a fit on there and we use our X train
that we separated out with our y train
now let's go ahead and run this so once
we've run this we'll have a model that
fits this data that 70 percent of our
training data
uh and of course the princess out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word deal we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example and there's nothing
in here that really stands out as super
important until you start fine-tuning it
but for what we're doing the basics will
work just fine and then let's we need to
go ahead and test out our model is it
working so let's create a variable y
predict and this is going to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the SK learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the Y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x test so we
have our train set and our test set and
now we're going to do our y predict and
let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y predict
let me go ahead and run that you'll see
it comes up and it presents and I prints
a nice array of B and M for B9 and
malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and it's
functional was very easy to create
you'll always discover with our data
science that as you explore this you
spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data and making sure your
data coming in is good there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it selecting
your models becomes the next part as far
as how good your models are and then of
course fine-tuning it depending on what
model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here log model dot predict X
test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrix we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the model
data and let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true and our
prediction what our model predicted for
that date on the test side
let's run that and see what that does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have a Precision for B9 and malignant B
and M
and we have a Precision of 93 and 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92 there's all kinds
of different information on here your F1
score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this I'll go
I'll go back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the Precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout I had up
above some of the numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91 percent accuracy so we look back
here let's we will see where we have B9
and England it actually is 92 coming up
here but we're looking about a 92 91
percent precision and remember I
reminded you about domains and we're
talking about the domain of a medical
domain with a very catastrophic outcome
you know at 91 or 92 percent Precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92 percent chance you're
going to earn 10 percent and eight
percent chance you're going to lose
eight percent you're probably going to
bet the money because at that odds it's
pretty good that you'll make some money
and in the long run you do that enough
you definitely will make money and also
with this domain I've actually seen him
use this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate so that wraps up
this section we're finally we're going
to go in there and let's discuss the
answer to the quiz asked in machine
learning tutorial part one
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag of words
approach so if you've gotten in there
that you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like k-means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up B identifying
handwritten digits and images correctly
this is an example of classification the
traditional approach to solving this
would be to extract digit dependent
features like curvature of different
digits Etc and then use a classifier
like sbm to distinguish between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example give yourself a
thumb up and if you're able to go hey
let's use svm or another model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
C behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed this
is an example of anomaly detection in
this case the algorithm learns what is
normal and what is not normal usually by
observing the logs or the website give
yourself a thumbs up if you got that one
and just for a bonus can you think of
another example of anomaly detection one
of the ones I use it for my own business
is detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickled and they
behave very radical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic with
something released in social media with
something released you can see we're
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual cool and if you guess that
this was a regression model give
yourself a thumbs up and if you're able
to remember that it is between
independent and dependent variables and
that terms give yourself two thumbs up
we're going to cover mathematics for
machine learning so today's agenda is
going to cover data and its types then
we're going to dive into linear algebra
and its Concepts calculus statistics for
machine learning probability for machine
learning Hands-On demos
and of course thrown in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data in its types data denotes the
individual pieces of factual information
collected from various sources it is
stored process and later used for
analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers and then you have
your performing analytics to drive
insights and hopefully you have a nice
share your shareholders gather it at the
meeting and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data's types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
uh but let's dive into this what we mean
by nominal nominal they are used to
label various uh label our variables
without providing any measurable value
uh country gender race hair color
Etc it's something that you either mark
true or false this is a label it's on or
off either they have a red hat on or
they do not so a lot of times when
you're thinking nominal data labels uh
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it and you can think of salary
range as a great one movie ratings Etc
you see here the salary range if you
have ten thousand to twenty thousand
number of employees earning that rate is
150. twenty thousand to thirty thousand
a hundred and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket this is where you
have 10 different buckets and you want
to separate it into something that makes
sense into those 10 buckets and so when
we start talking about ordinal a lot of
times when you get down to the
breastbones again we're talking true
false so if you're a member of the 10 to
20K Reigns so so forth those would each
be either part of that group or you're
not but now we're talking about buckets
and we want to count how many people are
in that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes discrete or continuous and
so data with a final set of values which
can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and Cricket a lot of times when you
see this you can think integer and a
very restricted integer I.E you can only
have 100 questions on a test so you can
it's very discreet I only have a hundred
different values that it can attain so
think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
uh so discrete is very solid simple to
count set number continuous on the other
hand continuous data can take any
numerical value within a range so water
pressure weight of a person Etc usually
we start thinking about float values
where they can get phenomenally small in
their in what they're worth and there's
a whole series of values that falls
right between discrete and continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 to
580.67 cents there's a lot of Point
values in there it'd still be called
discrete but you start looking at it as
almost continuous because it does have
such a variance in it now we talk about
no we did we went over nominal and
ordinal uh almost true false charts and
we looked at quantitative and numerical
data data which we'll start to get into
numbers discrete you can usually a lot
of times discrete will be put into it
could be put into true false but usually
it's not so we want to address this
stuff and the first thing we want to
look at is the very basic which is your
algebra so we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your euclidean geometry we have a
line well let's go through this we have
a linear algebra as the domain of
mathematics concerning linear equations
and the representations in Vector spaces
and through matrixes I told you we're
going to talk about Matrix is uh so a
linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4 y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them and that's
we're talking about a linear equation
and the vectors we have a plus b equals
c now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x y z plot so each one is a
direction and the actual distance of
like a triangle a b is C and then your
Matrix can describe all kinds of things
I find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things are used for
and a matrix is a chart or a you know
think of a spreadsheet but you have your
rows and your columns and you'll see
here we have a times b equals c very
important to know your counts uh so
depending on how the math is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number there's all kinds of
things that play in that that can make
matrixes confusing but really it has a
lot more to do with what domain you're
working in are you adding in multiple
polynomials where you have like uh a x
squared plus b y plus you know you start
to see they can be very confusing versus
a very straightforward Matrix and let's
just go a little deeper into these
because these are such primary this is
what we're here to talk about is these
different math mathematical computations
that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of one
is called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have ax plus b equals c which is
a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a X plus b y plus z c z equals D and
so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see X cubed so we're talking about
linear equations that's what we're
talking about in their addition if you
have already dived into say neural
networks you should recognize this ax
plus b y plus CZ
setup plus The Intercept which is
basically your your neural network each
node adding up all the different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals MX plus
c
so you have your y equals the M which is
your slope your X Value Plus C which is
your y-intercept I kind of labeled it
wrong here
threw me for a loop but the the C would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to 0 y equals c and that's that's
your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they they just had a
reverse value of y when x equals 0
equals the y-intercept which is C and
your slope gradient line which is your M
so use your y equals two X plus three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the one of the most important
takeaways is the slope gradient of the
line so the slope is very important that
M value in this case we went ahead and
solved this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking M rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the First Column similarly
a 12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a of Row one column
two first row and second column and so
on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
I've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or I
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize there
needs to be some designation as far as
what row it's in and what column it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have uh two matrixes of two
by two and you just add each individual
number in that Matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have in this case
the solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5
plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same thing
with subtraction
now again your counting Matrix is you
want to check your dimensions of the
Matrix the shape you'll see shape come
up a lot in programming so we're talking
about Dimensions we're talking about the
shape if the two shapes are equal this
is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up at the
very a slightly different setup going
now if we look at our last one where
we're like why this always gets to me
when we get to matrixes because they
don't really say why you multiply
matrixes
um you know my first thought is one
times two four times three but if you
look at this we get one times two plus
four times three one times three plus
four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation and so
we have if you remember when we back up
here for our multiple line equations
let's just go back up a couple slides
where we were looking at uh two
variables so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
um and this is a way to make it very
quick to solve these variables and
that's why you have the Matrix and
that's why you do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the dot product of uh one times
two plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little uh 14 23
21 and 33 over here which then can be
used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs and then in
Matrix operations when you're dealing
with a lot of matrixes now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes okay
so we're talking about multiplication
we're talking about solving for
equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding one times
two keep that in mind because that does
come up I've had that come up a number
of times where I'm altering data and I
get confused as to what I'm doing with
it
transpose flipping the Matrix over its
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14 821 you're
just flipping the columns in the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal and you can see here
we have the inverse a to the minus 1 and
ends up with a set of 12 8 14 12 is now
minus 22 minus 12. vectors Vector just
means we have
a value and a Direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector so if you have your X
plot and you have a single value that
value is along the x axis and it's a
single Dimension if you have two
Dimensions you can think about putting
them on a graph you might have X and you
might have y and each value denotes a
direction and then of course the actual
distance is going to be the hypothesis
so that triangle and you can do that
with three dimensionals X Y and Z and
you can do it all the way to nth
Dimensions so when they talk about the K
means for categorizing and how close
data is together they will compute that
based on the Pythagorean theorem so you
would take the square of each value add
them all together and find the square
root and that gives you a distance as
far as where that point is where that
Vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one and it makes a very
easy comparison versus comparing 50 or
60 different numbers and that brings us
up to I Gene vectors and I Gene values
hygiene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and hygiene values the scalar values
that are associated to the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
two Dimensions X and Y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so if we take and
we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh B is your is
your you have a and b which is your I
Gene Vector 2 is the I Gene value so
we're altering all the values by two
that means we're maybe we're stretching
it out One Direction making it tall if
you're doing picture editing that's one
of the places this comes in but you can
see when you're transforming your
different information how you transform
it is then your hygiene value and you
can see here a vector after line Transit
transition we have 3A a a is the I Gene
Vector three is the iodine value so a
doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture and three is skewing in One
Direction and maybe a b is being skewed
another Direction and so you have a nice
tilted picture because you've altered it
by those by the hygiene values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this I'm going
to go through my trusted Anaconda into
my Jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new uh notebook
called linear algebra
since we are working in Python we're
going to use our numpy always import
that as NP or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series I'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
I went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when I run this we
have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which is
what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus 9 you
could almost look at this addition as
being
um
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a DOT t
plus b dot T remember that t flips some
and so if we do that we now get them uh
we now have 30 24 going the other way we
could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b I can also do a plus
b dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 3024 whether I
transpose A and B or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors I can go a minus B
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section and so I don't
have to put the print around it
um and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down the scaler so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is I
have uh this array here U and if I go a
times U
H we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply
it by every value in here so 2 times 30
is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
Dot product
and uh with this this is in a
two-dimensional vectors it is the
equivalent of two matrix multiplication
remember we were talking about matrix
multiplication uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our U and our V and then we're going to
go ahead and do if we take
the values and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the NP
dot dot of U comma
V
and we'll find when we do this we go
ahead and run this
uh we're going to get
370. so this is a strain multiplication
where they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our Dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition and of course
the Matrix you can get very complicated
on these or in this case we'll go ahead
and do let's create two complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of
um you know 12 10 4 6 4 31. we'll just
print out a so you can see what that
looks like here's print a
we print a out you can see that we have
a
two by three layer Matrix for a and we
can also put together always kind of fun
when you're playing with print values we
could do something like this we could go
in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with equals a run and this kind of
gives it a nice look here's your Matrix
that's all this is comma N means it just
tags it on the end that's all all that
is doing on there and then we can simply
add in what is a plus b and you should
already guess because this is the same
as what we did before there's no
difference we do a simple vector
addition we have 12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus
8 is 18 and so on
and just like we did The Matrix Edition
we can also do a minus B into our Matrix
subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus eight uh where
are we
oh there we go eight minus ah
confusing what I'm looking at I should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is
minus 42 and so forth so same as its
attraction as before we just call it
Matrix subtraction it's identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication and so simply if you have
a single value a and you have B which is
your array we can also do a times B
when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4 is 8 5 times 4 is 20 and
so forth you're just multiplying the 4
across each one of these values and this
is an interesting one that comes up a
little bit of a brain teaser is Matrix
and Vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this
uh we are let's do a regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array we have a
which has our array of arrays and B
which is a single array and so we can
from here
do the DOT
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the verse value is that it's you
could say it's like uh we're doing the
this array B array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match when you get into
really complicated uh back end stuff
this becomes more common because you're
now you've got layers upon layers of
data and so you you'll end up with a
matrix and a set of Bolt Vector matrixes
do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes so if you're in the
side kit looking at SK learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the sci kit and if we can do
um
up here we did a matrix and Vector
multiplication we can also do Matrix to
matrix multiplication and if we run this
where we have the two matrixes you can
see we have a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our DOT and just to reiterate it we have
our transposer Matrix which is your dot
t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from 5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25 10 20
30. uh rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
um it also comes up a lot with X Y
plotting when you put into Pi plot you
have one format where they're looking at
Pairs and numbers and then they want L
of x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity Matrix
and this one is more definition
uh the identity Matrix we have here one
where we just did two so it comes down
as one zero zero one one zero zero zero
one zero it creates a diagonal of one
and what that is is when you're doing
your identities you could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have a
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always one where usually
it's between zero one depending on how
well correlates so when we're talking
about identity Matrix that's what we're
talking about right here is that you
create this preset Matrix and then you
might adjust these numbers depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh piece of
this puzzle here is an inverse a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
oh that's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh the website for
numpy so given a square Matrix a here's
our Square Matrix a which is two one
zero zero one zero one two one keep in
mind three by three it's Square it's got
to be equal it's going to return the
Matrix a inverse satisfying dot a a
inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
um and then of course it equals the dot
uh yeah a inverse of a with an identity
shape of uh a DOT shape zero this is
just reshaping the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see what we end up with is we end up
with an array 0.5 minus 0.5 and so forth
with our two one one going down two one
zero zero one zero one two one
um getting into a little deep on the
math understanding when you need this is
probably really is is what's really
important when you're doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a so if
it comes up you can easily pull it up or
at least remember where to look it up we
took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so calculus oh
my goodness and differential equations
you got to throw that in there because
that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end so when it comes up
you really do need to understand from
the data science not data analytics data
analytics means you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
so we talk about calculus we're going to
go ahead and understand it by talking
about cars versus time and speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous rate of change
so suppose we plot a graph with a speed
of a car with respect to time so as you
can see here going down the highway
probably merged into the highway from an
on-ramp so I had to accelerate so my
speed went way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and I accelerate again
up to the speed limit and maybe Peter's
off up there so you can look at this as
as
the speed versus time I'm getting faster
and faster because I'm continually
accelerating and if I hit the brakes it
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect to time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
start point of X and the endpoint of
Delta X
so we can calculate a simple if you had
X and Delta X we could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but I don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points I want to know it across the
whole of what I'm working with that's
where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between X
and Delta X it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is that instead of I mean if
you ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up let's go back
up a screen you divide this area up of
this time period up into maybe 10
sections and you'd use that and you
could calculate the acceleration between
each one of those 10 sections kind of
thing and then we just keep making that
space smaller and smaller until Delta X
is almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a equals a
limit as H goes to zero of a function of
a plus h minus a function of a over H
and that is your Computing the slope of
the line
we're just Computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice integral sign looks like a
giant s and that's what that means is
that we've taken this down to as small
as we can for that sampling uh so we're
talking about calculus we're finding the
area under the slope is the main process
in the integration similar small
intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of X Plus Delta X where
Delta X approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times D of x equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in W over change of time equals
change of w over change of Z the
differential of Z to DX differential of
x to DT it gets pretty complicated and
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x or y of D of a equals
the sum from C to D and A to B of f of x
or y d x d y equals the sum of a to B
sum of C to D of f x or y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is use the calculus one
calculus 2 and differential equations uh
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into and solve
these math equations what we want to
take from here is we're talking about
calculus we're talking about summing of
all these different slopes and so we're
still solving a linear uh expression
we're still solving y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infantismally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule when we come in here and
we have the change of w to the change of
T equals a change of w DZ uh and so
forth that's what's going on here that's
what these means we're basically looking
for the area under the curve which
really comes to how is the change
changing speeds going up how is that
changing and then you end up with a
multiple layer so if I have three layers
of neural networks how is a third layer
changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing and you get the picture
here that now we have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation so the nice thing is that
you don't have to solve this on paper
unless your data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model so it's really behind
the scenes we want to guess at what the
change or the change of the change is
that's a little goofy I I know I just
threw that out there's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our Target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and Global Maxima
and this is really big uh we're actually
going to have a whole section here on
gradient descent because it is really I
mean I talked about neural networks and
how you can see how the different layers
go in there but gradient descent is one
of the most key things for trying to
guess the best answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick
uh gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error uh hard to read
there and I want to make the error as
low as possible
and so when I'm looking at it is I want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down it goes here
and then goes back over here and then
goes a little bit closer and it's just
playing a high low until it gets to that
spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error in
uh on the flip note you could also want
to be maximizing something you want to
get the best output of it that's simply
minus the value so if you're looking for
where the peak is this is the same as a
negative for where the valley is I'm
looking for that Valley that's all that
is and this is a way of finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting's done I actually ended up
putting together one of these a while
back as uh when I didn't know about
sidekick and I was just starting boy
it's a long while back and uh is playing
high low how do you play high low not
get stuck in The Valleys figure out
these curves and things like that well
you do that and the back end is all the
calculus and differential equations to
calculate this out the good news is you
don't have to do those
uh so instead we're going to put
together the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun uh some things we're gonna
note and this is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models you're
going to find these things are stumbling
blocks the first one is current X where
do we start at keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start and we started at this
because the algorithm starts at x equals
three so we arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is how many bars to skip
going one way or the other in fact I'm
going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about well
here's our here's the function we're
going to use our gradient of our
function 2 times X plus five keep it
simple so that's a function we're going
to work with so if I'm dealing with
increments of a thousand point one is
going to be a very long time and if I'm
dealing with increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so I
won't get a very good answer and then we
look at Precision this tells us when to
stop the algorithm so again very
specific to what you're working on if
you're working with money
and you don't convert it into a float
value you might be dealing with 0.01
which is a penny that might be your
Precision you're working with
um and then of course the previous step
size Max iterations uh we want something
to cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
itters is less than Max and Max itters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our Precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper and then we also don't want to go
past a thou or whatever this is a
million or ten thousand uh running
that's actually pretty high I almost
never do Max iterations more than like a
hundred or two hundred rare occasions
you make up to four or five hundred if
it's uh depending on the problem you're
working with uh so we have our previous
equals our current that way we can track
time wise uh the current now equals the
current minus the rate times the formula
of our previous X
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
how we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at axon here and if
we go ahead and run this
uh you can see right here it gets down
to this point and it says hey
um local minimum is minus
3.322 for this particular series we
created and this is created off of our
formula here Lambda X2 times X Plus 5.
now
when I'm running this stuff you'll see
this come up a lot
and with the sklearn kit and one of the
nice reasons of breaking this down the
way we did is I could go over those top
pieces those top pieces are everything
when you start looking at these
minimization toolkits in built-in code
and so from
um we'll just do it's actually Docs
got
scipy.org and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated so
we use a very simple function up here it
could be there's all kinds of things
that could be on there and there's a
number of methods to solve this as far
as how they shrink down and your X
naught there's your there's your start
value so your function your start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really the big
thing I want to point out here is you
need to have a starting point you want
to start with something that you already
know is mostly the answer if you don't
then it's going to have a heck of a time
trying to calculate it out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well I guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an adult
class uh so a bunch of stuff going on
statistics statistics concerns with the
collection organization analysis
interpretation and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
um so we have from end to end where
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it how
do we analyze it and then you got to
take those analysis and interpret it
into something that uh people can use
kind of reduce it to understandable and
nowadays you have to be able to present
it if you can't present it then no one
else is going to understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in so clearly if you're working in a
domain that deals with
viruses and T cells and and how does you
know where does that come from you're
studying the different people then you
can have a population if you are working
with
um
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling statistics to know when to
replace a rotor on a machine or
something like that that can be a big
deal you know we have these huge fans
that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed so that's your population all
the objects it's easy to see it with
people because we have our population in
large but in the case of these sewer
fans we're talking about having the fan
units that's the population of fans that
we're working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample sometimes you
don't have a choice you can only take a
sample of what's going on you can't
study the whole population and a
variable a metric of interest for each
person or object in a population
types of sampling we have probabilistic
approach selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective Judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection has to do with convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
uh and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
it says biased uh so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling uh when we
talk about a random sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category so we it's as random as you can
get uh we talk about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
uh so we kind of split it up this would
be like a Time setup or a different
categories and you might ask your
question what is a category or a group
uh if you look at I'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from they might
need to be separated and so uh and when
I say separated I don't mean separated
from their their place where they live I
mean as far as the analysis we want to
look at the different groups and make
sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 uh of a group
that is uh say Hispanic and or Indian
and also in that same area we have 20 20
who are let's call our expatriates they
left America and they're nice and uh
your Caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both uh so we're talking about
stratified sampling and we're talking
about groups those are the groups we're
talking about and that brings us to
stratified sampling selecting
approximately equal size samples from
each group or category
uh this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of depends on what you're
working with as far as your data and
what you're studying and so we can see
here just to go a little bit more we'd
have selecting 25 employees from a
company of 250 employees randomly don't
care anything about them what groups are
in which office they're in nothing
uh and we might be selecting one
employee from every 50 unique employees
in a company of 250 employees and then
we have selecting one employee from
every branch in the company office so we
have all the different branches there's
our group or our categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also used
to generate a lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is then everybody
assumes that's what it is for everybody
and so you've got to be very careful of
that and it's very unethical thing to
kind of do
so types of Statistics uh we talk about
statistics we're going to talk about
descriptive and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up uh so we so
we're talking about a particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive and
inferential uh statistics the base of
the word describe is pretty solid you're
describing the data what does it look
like with inferential statistics we're
going to take that from the small
population to a large population so if
you're working with a drug company you
might look at the data and say these
people were helped by this drug they did
80 better as far as their health or 80
percent better survival rate than the
people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
Tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second but one
of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max Min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central Tendencies measure
of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of
whatever's going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it so that the average is much
higher than if you took those outliers
out where the median would by separating
the high from the low might give you a
much lower number you might look at and
say oh that's that's odd Y is the
average so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value this is really
interesting if you're studying economics
and how people are doing you might find
that the most common
income like in the U.S was at 1.24 000 a
year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all Central Tendencies
single numbers you can look at for the
whole spread of the data
and we look at the measure of central
Tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a student's in a classroom so here we
have the mean some of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median if we have 0
through 10 and we take half the numbers
and put them on one side of the line
half the numbers on the other side of
the line we end up with five in the
middle and then the mode what Mark was
scored by most of the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the oh
let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group of scores that makes
thirty thousand and a slightly bigger
group that makes twenty six thousand so
what do you put down for the mode
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing so now we're looking at a
measure of spread uh range what's the
difference between the highest and the
lowest value first thing you want to
look at you know it's uh we had
everybody in the test scored between 60
and 100 so we got 100 or maybe 60 to 90
percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get 100 percent
um you have your interquartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into four equal parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in uh data frames with pandas
whether you're working in Scala whether
you're working in R you'll see this come
up where they have range your Min your
Max and then it'll have your
interquartile range how does it look
like in each quarter of data variance
measures how far each number in the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
uh so you have like how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is
the measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if I'm doing a
graph I might have the value graphed
um and then based on the the error I
might grab graph the standard deviation
in the error on the graph as a
background so you can see how far off it
is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of 100 we have here from 50
to 63 or 50 to 90 so the range maximum
marks minimum marks we have 90 to 45 and
the spread of that is 45 90 minus 45 and
then we have the interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is and then
there's a first quarter the second
quarter and the third quarter based on
splitting it apart by those values and
to understand the variance and standard
deviation we first need to find out the
mean so here's our you know calculating
the average there we end up
approximately 66 for the average and
then we look at that in the variance
once we know the means we can do equals
the marks minus the mean squared Y is a
squared because one you want to make
sure it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower so you
always see the squared value and over
the total observations and so the
standard deviation equals the square
root of the variance which is
approximately 16. and if you were
looking at a predictable model you would
be looking at the deviation based on the
error how much error does it have that's
again really important to know if your
if your prediction is predicting
something what's a chance of it being
way off or just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
Python code so you can get some little
Hands-On here for that let's go back
into our Jupiter notebook in Python now
almost all of this you can do in numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name Jane
Michael William Rosie Hannah sat in
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this uh like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
I go ahead and do this print DF pick our
column salary because we want to find
the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
uh and we go and print this out and you
can see that the average income on here
is 71
000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part the
means is the average uh and then the
median
oops let's put a
median here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better we can see
the median is 54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000. darn you Rosie for
throwing off our numbers but that's
something you'd want to notice this is
this is the difference between these is
huge and so is what is the meaning
behind that when you're studying a
populace and looking at the different
data coming in and of course we also
want to find out hey what's the most
common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at fifty thousand
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making fifty thousand
the middle point is at fifty four
thousand so half the people are making
more than that what that tells me is
that if the most common income is way is
below the median then there's a few
there's a you know there's a lot of high
salaries going up but there's some
really low salaries in there and so this
trend which is very common in statistic
and when you're in analyzing the economy
in different people's income is pretty
common and the bigger difference between
these is also very important when we're
studying statistics and when you hear
someone just say hey the average income
was you might start asking questions at
that point why aren't you talking about
the median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding and if you're doing
these analysis you should be looking at
these saying hey why are this
discrepancies why are these so different
and of course with any analysis it's
important to find out the minimum them
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply
dot min
so pull up your minimum and then dot Max
pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing what you're
you know put the your lowest value and
what your highest value is here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode note that it puts mode zero like I
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
although the standard one's pretty good
we can of course do the range which is
your max minus your Min so now we have a
range of 149 000 between the upper end
and the lower end and you might want to
be looking at the individual values on
all of these but it turns out there is a
describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do DF
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven
setups here's our mean our standard
deviation which we didn't compute yet
which would just be a DOT STD and you
gotta be a little careful because when
it computes it it looks for axes and
things like that we have our minimum
value and here's our quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary uh so these are these are
the basic statistics you can pull them
up and just describe this is a
dictionary so I could actually do
something like um
and here I could actually go uh count
and run and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need now if I just walked in and
gave you this information in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep that's what I would do
anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here we'll go ahead and put
it into a histogram and plot that graph
on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a Jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically but just in case I
always put it in there import matplot
library pipelot is PLT that's my
plotting
and then we have our data frame uh I
guess I really don't need to respell the
data frame maybe we could just remind
ourselves what's in it so we'll go ahead
and just print
DF that way we still have it and then we
have our salary DF salary salary.plot
history title salary distribution color
gray
uh plot axvline salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style Dash this is
just all making it pretty uh what color
dash line line width of two that kind of
thing and the median and let's go ahead
and run this just so you can see what
we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame printed out so you can see it with
the salaries we'll look at the salary
distribution and just look at this the
way there the salary is distributed
you have our in this case we did Let's
see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it really I mean here's our
outlier here's our person who makes a
lot of money here's the average and
here's the median
um and so as you look at this you can
say wow um based on the average it
really doesn't tell you much about what
people are really taking home all it
does is tell you how much money is in
this you know what the average salary is
so some of the things you want to take
away in addition to this is that it's
very easy to plot
um
an axv line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
and as you just display the data I mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward I look
at this and I can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that but you
know pictures worth a thousand words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe which pulls all this
information out and we can print any of
the individual information from the
describe because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
Statistics being able to
doesn't have the print on there so it's
only going to print the last one which
happens to be the mean you can very
easily reference any one of these and
then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics you
can come through and pull any one of the
individual
um
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data let's get into
inferential statistics inferential
statistics allows you to make
predictions or inferences from data and
you can see here we have a nice little
picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in the study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked 35 chance of saying disliked or a
10 or 11 chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at Point estimation uh
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean or average from
random samples of the population let's
take an example of testing vaccines for
covid-19 vaccines and flu bugs all that
it's a pretty big thing of how do you
test these out and make sure they're
going to work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's a protected here's
our small group up here where we've
selected them we run medical trials on
them and then the results work for the
population a nice diagram with the
arrows going back and forth in the very
scary coveted virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very Central is what they call
hypotheses testing uh and the confidence
interval which go with that and then as
we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is used to measure
the plausibility of a hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorems Theory
hypothesis keep in mind that if you are
in a philosophy class theory is the same
as hypothesis where theorem is a
scientific statement that is something
that has been proven although it is
always up for debate because in science
we always want to make sure things are
up to debate so a hypothesis is the same
as a philosophical class calling a
theory where theory in science is not
the same theory in science says this has
been well proven gravity is a theory so
if you want to debate the theory of
gravity try jumping up and down if you
want to have a theory about why the
economy is collapsing in your area that
is a philosophical debate very important
I've heard people mix those up and it is
a pet peeve of mine when we talk about
hypotheses testing the steps involved in
hypotheses testing is first we formulate
a hypothesis we figure out the right
test to test our hypothesis we execute
the test and we make a decision and so
when you're talking about hypothesis
you're usually trying to disprove it if
you can't disprove it and it works for
all the facts then you might call that a
theorem at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day Rob took the opportunity to
make chits and wrote everyone's name on
it so here's our four people Nick Rob
imlia imlia and summer
now Rick Emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether Rob has done some
Mischief in preparing the chits I.E
whether Rob has written his name on one
of the chit for that we will find out
the probability of Rob getting the
cleaning job on first day second day
third day and so on till 12 days the
probability of Rob getting the job
decreases every day I.E his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some Mischief while making the chits so
the probability of Rob not doing work on
day one is three out of four there's a
0.75 chance that he didn't do work uh
two days three fourths times
three-fourths equals 0.56
three days you have three fours three
fourths three-fourths which equals point
four two
uh when you get to day 12 it's 0.032
Which is less than 0.05 remember this
0.05 that comes up a lot when we're
talking about
um certain values when we're looking at
statistics Rob is cheating as he wasn't
chosen for 12 consecutive days that's a
very high probability when on day 12 he
still hasn't gotten the job cleaning the
room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomenon or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states whenever
something is happening a new theory is
preferred instead of an old one and so
the two hypotheses go hand in hand uh so
your null this is always interesting in
in when talking about data science and
the math behind it it's about proving
that the things have no correlation null
hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other where the
alternative hypothesis says hey we found
a relation this is what it is we have
p-value the p-value is a probability of
finding the observed or more extreme
results when the null hypotheses of a
study question is true
and the T value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of T the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the T values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p-value is derived from your T
value and you're looking for what is
called a five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug and this is a good one
because the null value here isn't that
you don't have any drug then null value
here is it is better than existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation and the new drug is not
doing its job the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug uh yay we got a new drug out there
and that's our alternative hypothesis or
the H1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for a 0.05 or
five percent and the T value comparing
all the positive test results and
finding means of different samples in
order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals a confidence interval is a
range of values we are sure our true
values of observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 percent of our values lie in
that data spread uh and this the graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here where
you have the 95 percent you have your
peak in this case it's a normal
distribution so you have a nice bell
curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and 95 percent of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis and we're
going to move into probability so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
search and T can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence score
prediction how good you're going to do
in whatever sport you're in weather
prediction stock prediction if you've
studied physics and Chaos Theory even
the location of the chair you're sitting
on has a probability that it might move
three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh I think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability that we don't see them so we
talk about random variable uh random
variable is a variable whose possible
values are numerical outcomes of a
random phenomena so we have the coin
toss how many heads will occur in the
series of 20 coin flips probably you
know the on average they're 10 but you
really can't know because it's very
random how many times a red ball is
picked from a bag of balls if there's
equal number of red balls and blue balls
and green balls in there how many times
the sum of digits on two dice results
are five each
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
Dives
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice and instead of
looking at how many times
um both dice for roll five let's go
ahead and look at total sum of five and
you have in as far as your random
variables you can have a one four equals
five four one two three three two
so four of those roles can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random roles can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you're gonna have an outcome of
five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that but let's just
consider this is one of the cases is
rolling two dice and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution it
is the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or filling an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs Barcelona and Dortmund the
teams will have to play a total of four
matches and we have to find out the
chances of Barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches let's say that the winning
chance for Barcelona is 75 percent or
0.75 that means at each game they have a
75 chance that they're going to win that
game and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals one so
that accounts for a hundred percent of
the game probability for getting K wins
in in matches is calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games uh and you want to know if I
play
um how many wins in those five games
should I get what's a percentage on
those and the probability for getting K
wins and in matches is calculated by p x
equals k equals nck P to the k q to the
N minus K here p is a probability of
success and Q is the probability of
failure and so we can do total games of
n equals five where k equals zero one
two three four five P which is the
chance of winning is 0.75 Q the chance
of losing equals one minus P which
equals one minus 0.075 which equals 0.25
the probability that Barcelona will lose
all of the matches can then just plug in
the numbers and we end up with a point
zero zero zero nine seven six five six
two five so very small chance they're
going to lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability of the Barcelona
will win at least two matches is 0.0878
and of course we can go on to the
probability of the Barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information
um and let's find the accumulated
discrete probabilities for each of the
outcomes where Barcelona has won three
or more matches x equals three x equals
four x equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of Barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75 and it's
always nice to uh put out a nice graph
so you can actually see the number of
wins to the probability and how that
pans out with our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
uh but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening out to the
left and you have right skewed data and
so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that mostly you end up
with a normalized set of data but you
got to also be aware that sometimes it's
a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice Peak and so
being aware of this that you might have
a probability that fits certain data but
it has a lot of outliers so you're if
you have a really high standard
deviation if you're doing stock market
analysis this means your predictions are
probably not going to make you much
money where if you have a very small
deviation you might be right on Target
and set to become a millionaire which
leads us to the z-score z-score tells
you how far from the mean a data point
is it is measured in terms of standard
deviations from the mean around 68
percent of the results are found between
one standard deviation around 95 percent
of the results are found between two
standard deviations and you read the
symbols of course they love to throw
some Greek letters in there we have mu
minus two Sigma mu is just a quick ways
that kind of funky you it just means the
mean and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with that
little arrow off to the right or the
little waggly Tail Going Up deal with it
with a line on it so mu minus two Sigma
is your 95 of the results are found
between two standard deviations
Central limit theorem this goes back to
the skew if you remember we were looking
at the skew values on this previous
slide have left skewed normalized and
right skewed when we're talking about it
being skewed or not skewed the
distribution of the sample means will be
approximately normally distributed
evenly distributed not skewed if you
take large random samples from the
population with the mean mu and the
standard deviation Sigma with
replacement
and you can see here of course we have
our mu minus two Sigma on the spread
down here the mean the median and the
mode and so you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it and if you're going
to do all this we got to jump into
conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is a probability that the event will
occur given the knowledge that an event
to be has already occurred and you'll
see this as Bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s Bays
and this is red
I mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets a b this is the
probability of a being true while B is
already true
and you have the probability of B being
true when a is already true so P B of A
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of B being true
and we talk about Bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals J K and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice and so if you
have a set you might have eight or nine
different studies going on in different
areas different people have done the
studies they brought them together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread certainly the studies done
in China versus the studies the way
they're done in the U.S that data is
different in each of those studies but
if you can find a place where it
overlaps where they're studying the same
thing together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of one group and you want to find
out more about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science and understanding
where your data is coming from and how
you're going to combine different
studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking and
this is kind of interesting the way they
word this let's say that according to
medical report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients they treated suffered lung
disease so we have kind of a generic
medical report they further found out by
a survey that 15 percent of the patients
that visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and um 15 of the patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest Choice
um but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a uh
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease
and then probability B probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of B if B then a
the probability of a patient smokes even
though they have lung disease is five
percent
and probability of a is B probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of B probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 chance hence there
is a 3.33 chance that a person who
smokes will get a lung disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code and we're always my favorite
roll up the sleeves keep in mind we're
going to be doing this um kind of like
the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
um we'll get into another demo which
shows you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this let's start by
creating a set so we're going to create
a set with curly braces
this means that our set has only unique
values so you have a list you have your
tuples which can never change and then
you have in this case the the set so
four seven you can't create a four seven
comma four it'll delete the four outs
it's only unique values and if you use
dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary where you
have a value and that value is assigned
to or that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven
we can also take a list of regular setup
and I'm going to go ahead and just throw
in another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if I
take my list one two three four four and
I convert it to a set and here it is my
set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set 6 is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get 3 is in the set true one is in
the set false because three five seven
is another one six is in the Set uh six
is not in the set so not in my set
you can also use this with a list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have the same response on
there is three and usually you do if
three is in but three in my set is still
works on just a regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
um uh one two three four five six and so
we're going to bring in that iteration
tool and import product as product
and I'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values uh
you can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to
seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the seven and the same thing for our
dice B
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of A and B so what's a plus b now if we
go ahead and run this it'll print that
out and you'll see in this case when
they say product because it's an
iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice where
dice a is one two three one to six and
dice B is one to six and you can see one
to one one to two one to three and so
forth you remember we had a slide on
this earlier where we talked about the
different all the different outcomes of
a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit we can do in dice equals two div
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces repeat equals
end Dice and we're going to just run
this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before we can just go through
four outcome and event space outcome and
equals
so the event space is creating
uh sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it Stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the End Printing with a
comma that just means it's just gonna
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line and we'll go ahead
and do the links
of our event space uh I'll be a
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if I get carried away with
my typing of links I will print it twice
and it'll give me an error so we have 36
different possible variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
um what about the multiple of three what
if we want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of X Y
equals outcome if X Plus y
remainder three so we're going to divide
by 3 and look at the remainder and it
equals zero
then it's a fable outcome and we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
uh because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
uh multiples of three uh one plus two is
three five plus four is nine which
divided by three is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the links uh
of the one before let's go ahead and
print
the length
of our F outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course I did forget to add the
print in the middle because We're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if I run
this you can see uh
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily convert the
probability of this by simply taking the
length of our favorable outcome over the
length of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with a 0.33333 Chance
that's roughly a third
and we might want to make this look nice
so let's go ahead and put in another
line there the probability of getting
the sum which is a multiple of three is
0.333333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
ahead and run it you can see we just
have a huge amount of choices so just
goes on and on down here and we can look
at the length of the event space
and we have over seven thousand seven
hundred and seventy six choices that's a
lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh what is the sum where
the sum is a multiple of five but not a
multiple of three
we can go through all of these different
options and then you can see here D1 D2
D3 D4 D5 equals the outcome and if you
add these all together and the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero but the remainder is
also of a division by three is not equal
to zero so the multiple of five is equal
to zero but the multiple three is not we
can just append that on here and then we
can look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
six and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll a multiple of five
when you add them together
but not a multiple of three
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.116255 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated in
math right here on probabilities it's
just how many options do you have and
how many of those are you possibly going
to be able to come up with with the
solution you're looking for and this
leads us to a confusion Matrix
a confusion Matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the True Values are known
and so you'll see on the left we have
the predicted and the actual and we have
a negative false negative positive true
positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of us to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it true
positive versus uh false positive we get
a false positive response and you can
imagine in medical uh situations this is
a pretty big deal you don't want to give
a false positive so you might adjust
your model accordingly so you don't have
a false positive say with a covet virus
test it'd be better to have a false
negative and they go back and get
retested then to have 30 percent false
positives where then the test is pretty
much invalid so in a use case like
cancer prediction let's consider an
example where a cancer prediction model
is put to the test for its accuracy and
precision actual result of a person's
medical report is compared with the
prediction made by the machine learning
model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a false positive
I mean a false negative in other words
you don't want to have it tell you that
you don't have cancer when you do so
that would be something you'd really be
looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative
uh and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in there's a real famous case
study where they have the imagery and
all the measurements they take and
there's about 36 different measurements
they take and then if you run the a
basic model you want to know just how
accurate is how many negative results do
you have that are either telling people
they have cancer that don't or telling
people that don't have cancer that they
do and then we can take these numbers
and we can feed them into our accuracy
our precision and our recall
uh so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the true
negative over all the results so what
percentage of them were accurate versus
what were wrong
we'll talk about Precision is the metric
to measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
uh so we have a Precision on true
positive again if you're talking about
like uh covid testing with the viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this true that to be the center
point where you might have the opposite
if you're dealing with cancer where you
want no false negatives
uh so this is your metric on here
Precision is your test positive uh true
positive plus uh false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model uh so
test positive is the test positive plus
the false negative on there and we'll
want to go ahead and do a demo on the
naive Bayes classifier before I get too
far into uh naive Bay's classifier
because we're going to pull it from the
SK learn or the sci kit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers when you go
into the SK learn kit there's a lot of
ways to do classification and I'll just
zoom up in here so you can see some of
the titles uh there's everything from
the nearest neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive Bayes over here and this is just a
sample data set that they put together
and you can see how some of these have a
very different output the naive Bayes
remember is set up as probably the most
simplified calculator or setup
addictions out there and so what we've
been talking about with the true false
and stuff like that where there's a
an A belief that there is a independent
assumption between the features where
the features are very assumed to have
some kind of connection uh then we can
go ahead and use that for the prediction
and so that's what we're using is a
naive Bayes classifier versus many of
the other classifiers that are out there
for this we're going to use uh The
Social Network ads it's a little data
set on here and let me go and just open
that up the file
here we go it has user ID gender age
estimated salary uh purchased and so we
have you can see the user ID mail 19
it's made salary 19000 and purchase zero
so it's either gonna make a purchase or
not so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
Bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as NP
I'm going to nice to have a good visual
of our data so we'll put in our matplot
library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be we're going to read it from
The Social Network ads.csv then we're
going to print the head just so you can
see it again even though I showed you it
in the file and x equals the data set I
location
two three values and Y is going to be
the 4 column four let me just run this
so it's a little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at 0 1 2 is age and estimated
salary so 2 3
and that's what I location just means um
that we're looking at the number versus
a regular location a regular location
you'd actually say age an estimated
salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
uh so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and imported the data so now our data
set is all set with this information in
it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
date up so we need our from the SK learn
model selection we can import train test
split uh this does a nice job we can set
the random state so it randomly picks
the data and we're just going to take 25
percent of it's going to go into the
test our X test and our y test and the
75 will go to x train and Y train that
way once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules and setup you should start
noticing that we bring in our data we
take a look at what we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of minus one and one
or someplace in the Middle Ground there
this way if you have any huge set you
don't have this huge setup if we go back
up to here where salary salary is 20 000
versus age 35. well there's a good
chance with a lot of the back end math
that 20 000 will skew the results and
the estimated salary will have a higher
impact than the age instead of balancing
them out and letting the calculations
weigh them properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive Bayes model
um and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive Bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the SK
learn kit they have a number of
different ones you can pull in there
there's a
um Bernoulli I don't know I've never
used that one categorical
um complement and here's our gaussian so
there's a number of different options
you can look at gaussian when you come
to the naive Bayes is the most commonly
used so we're talking about the naive
Bayes that's usually what people are
talking about when they when they're
pulling this in and one of the nice
things about the gaussian if you go to
their website to sklearn the naibes
gaussian there's a lot of cool features
one of them is you can do partial fit on
here that means if you have a huge
amount of data you don't have to process
it all at once you once you can batch it
into the gaussian NB model and there's
many other different things you can do
with it as far as fitting the data and
how you manipulate it we're just doing
the basics so we're going to go ahead
and create our classifier we're going to
equal the gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so X train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict X test so here we fit
the data and now we're going to go ahead
and predict
and now we get to our confusion Matrix
so from the SK learn Matrix metrics you
can import your confusion Matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the Y test and
the Y predict so we have our actual and
we have our predicted value and you can
see from here this is the chart we
looked at here's predicted so true
positive false positive false negative
true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3725
and in this particular prediction we had
65 uh were predicted the truth as far as
a purchase they're going to make a
purchase and we guessed three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion Matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting you
would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion Matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine's going
to throw an error because this is being
um
because of the way the setup is I have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo and we need our xset
and our y set which is our X train and Y
train
and then we'll create our X1 X2
and we'll put that into a grid and we
set our xset minimum stop and our X at
Max stop and if we come all the way over
here we're going to step 0.01 this is
going to give us a nice line is what
that's doing and then we're going to
plot the Contour
plot the X limit plot the Y limit and
put the scatter plot in there let's go
ahead and run this to be honest when I'm
doing these graphs there's so many
different ways to do that there's so
many different ways to put this code
together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that that's defined by the naive Bayes
setup and then we have those who did
make a purchase the green and you can
see that some of the green Drops Fall
Into the red area and some of the red
dots fall into the green so even our
training set isn't going to be a hundred
percent we couldn't do that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
we can kind of arrange our X1 X2 so we
have a nice plot going on and then we're
going to create the Contour
that's that nice line that's drawn down
the middle on here with the red green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to uh
do the dot T if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module you end up
with pairs you know X X1 X2 x 1 x 2 next
row and so forth you have to flip it so
it's all one row you have all your X
ones and all your x2s so that's what
we're kind of looking for right here on
this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course your scattered data across there
we're just going through all the points
that puts these nice little dots onto
our setup on here and we have our
estimated salary and our age and then of
course the dots are did they make a
purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
xset yset equals x train y train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition so it's this own
module that could be called over and
over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results that way we can see what
happened with our test group our 25
percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set and it if you look at the two
graphs next to each other this one
obviously has 75 percent of the data so
it's going to show a lot more
this is only 25 percent of the data you
can see that there's a number that are
kind of on the edge as to whether they
could guess by age and income they're
going to make a purchase or not but that
said it still is pretty clear it's
pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now graphs are really effective for
showing people what's going on but you
also need to have the numbers and so
we're going to do from sklearn we're
going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification Port from the Y
test and the Y predict
and you can see here we have Precision
Precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an F1 score and a support
and we have our Precision the recall on
getting it right and then we can do our
accuracy the macro average and the
weighted average so you can see that it
pulls in pretty good as far as how
accurate it is you could say it's going
to be about 90 percent is going to guess
correctly
that it that they're not going to
purchase and we had an 89 chance that
they are going to purchase and then the
other numbers as you get down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy and here's our micro
average and the weighted average and
everything else you might need and if
you forgot the exact definition of
accuracy it is the true positive true
negative over all of the different
setups Precision is your true positive
overall positives true and false and
recall is a true positive over truth
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here
here's our Precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this multiple
linear regression let's take a brief
look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so on multiple linear
regression we have well we'll start with
the simple linear regression where we
had y equals M plus X plus C and we're
trying to find the value of y now with
multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just X we have X1 X2 X3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have M1 M2 M3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the r d we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data to see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
libraries now I'm going to be doing this
in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy it because it's such
a visual to look look at it's so easy to
use just any ID for python will work
just fine for this so break out your
favorite python IDE so here we are in
our jupyter notebook let me go ahead and
paste our first piece of code in there
and let's walk through what libraries
were importing first we're going to
import numpy as NP and then I want you
to skip one line and look at import
pandas as PD these are very common tools
that you need with most of your linear
regression the numpy which stands for
number python is usually denoted as NP
and you have to almost have that for
your SK learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning pandas
although you don't have to have it for
your sklearn libraries it does such a
wonderful job of importing data setting
it up into a data frame so we can
manipulate it rather easily and it has a
lot of tools also in addition to that so
we usually like to use the pandas when
we can and I'll show you what that looks
like the other three lines are for us to
get a visual of this data and take a
look at it so we're going to import
matplot Library dot pipelot as PLT and
then Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with
the matplot library so you have to
always import matplot library and then
Seabourn sits on top of it and we'll
take a look at what that looks like you
could use any of your own plotting
libraries you want there's all kinds of
ways to look at the data these are just
very common ones and the Seaborn is so
easy to use it just looks beautiful it's
a nice representation that you can
actually take and show somebody and the
final line is the Amber signed matplot
library in line that is only because I'm
doing an inline IDE my interface in the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook requires I put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent independent
variables now here in this slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies dot CSV
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have in the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the I location and
because this is companies is a PD data
set I can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so X is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a tech text editor and
you can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is so I can see the
data to me it doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
Investments and you understand what 165
349.20 compared to the administration
cost of 136
897.80 so on so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display and you can display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matplot library inline with the
Amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
Seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spending we have Administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with Administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have have a nice look at the data let's
go ahead and dig in and create some
actual useful linear regression models
so that we can predict values and have a
better profit now that we've taken a
look at the visualization of this data
we're going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is R and D
spending column one which is
Administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
State and you'll see under State we have
New York California Florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process New York it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that New York California and
Florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in Brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the X also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
encode or categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look at what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test a split we take X
and we take y we've already created
those X has the columns with the data in
it and Y has a column with profit in it
and then we're going to set the test
size equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting is it setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this or we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fit in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when I run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals True
Fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a why
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict X test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
I'm in Jupiter in line I can just put
the variable up there and when I hit the
Run button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into and where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals M1 times X1 plus M2
times X2 and so on and so on plus C the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the N plus C
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of two etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the Y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model remember it does have a
random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into jupyter notebook and show the
code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an eight by eight image and
there the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to predict what this number is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
let's set with the training set we train
our model and then with the S set we
test the model didn't we get good
accuracy and then we use it for for
inference right so that is typical
methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with the
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the confusion Matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
get an accuracy of about 0.94 which is
pretty good or 94 percent which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and this is used for
identifying the accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion Matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the Matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right so the most important
part here is that the model will be most
accurate when we have the maximum
numbers in its diagonal like in this
case that's why it has almost 93 94
percent because the diagonals should
have the maximum numbers and the others
other than diagnose the cells other than
the diagonal should have very few
numbers so here that's what is happening
so there is a two here there are there's
a one here but most of them are along
the diagonal this what does this mean
this means that the number that has been
fed is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and actual value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed are rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two missed
classifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this Matrix
how to use this confusion Matrix I know
the name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion Matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information on what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all right
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are I think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of Digit 3 and the accuracy
is only 37 of them have been accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven and two of
them have been predicted as number eight
and so on and so forth okay all right so
with that let's go into Jupiter notebook
and see how the code looks so this is
the code in in Jupiter notebook for
logistic regression in this particular
demo what we are going to do is train
our model to recognize digits which are
the images which have digits from let's
say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
part is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
okay if we take a look this is how the
shape is 1797 by 64. these are like 8 by
8 images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at 0 1 2 3 4. so this is how the image
is this is how the data is okay and
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an eight by eight pixel kind of
a image and the each pixel whether it is
activated or not activated that is the
information available for each pixel now
based on the pattern of this activation
and non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn for which
number what is the pattern of the
activation iteration of the pixels right
so that is what we are going to train
our model okay so the first thing we
need to do is to split our data into
training and test data set right so
whenever we perform any training we
split the data into training and tests
so that the training data set is used to
train the system so we pass this
probably multiple times and then we test
it with the test data set and the split
is usually in the form of there and
there are various ways in which you can
split this data it is up to the
individual preferences in our case here
we are splitting in the form of 23 and
77 so when we say test size as 20 or
0.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
space it so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and Y
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is the labeled data for each
of them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two so that that's this is what
will be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able
recognizes it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of there so X
underscore train the shape is 1383 by 64
and Y underscore train has 1383 because
there is nothing like the second part is
not required here and then X underscore
test shape we see is four one four so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are saying okay then we
import the logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit-learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these uh the function and let
me go ahead and execute that so that we
have the logistic regression Library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is uh is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our the predictors and this
is our Target we are passing this data
set to train our model all right so once
we do this in this case the data is not
large but by and large and the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is uh correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image and we see that the
shape is or the prediction is 4. so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 seems to be fine so let me just
go ahead and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has uh performed so we use the
score method to find what is the
percentages of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94 percent
accurate okay so that's on this part now
what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion Matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and um
we we basically create a confusion
Matrix an instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value same as
the predictive value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix in a slightly more
sophisticated way using a heat map so we
will create a heat map with some We'll
add some colors as well it's uh it's
like a more visually visually more
appealing so that's the whole idea so if
we let me run this piece of code and
this is how the heat map looks and as
you can see here the diagonals again are
all the values are here most of the
values so which means reasonably this
seems to be reasonably accurate and yeah
basically the accuracy score is 94
percent this is calculated as I
mentioned by adding all these numbers
divided by the total test value so the
total number of observations in test
data set okay okay so this is the
confusion Matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well uh the system
has classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of 9. so this has also been
predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images need for
confusion matrixes classification models
have multiple output categories most
error measures will tell us the total
error in our model but we cannot use it
to find out individual instances of
errors in our models so you have your
input coming in you have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh 53
of these are correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53 correct uh on guessing
on the spam is it 23 guessing on spam
and 27 guessing on what's not spam
this is where the confusion Matrix comes
in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems if there is a
significant class imbalance a model
might predict the majority class for all
cases and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted 8 out of ten
instruments and we'll have an accuracy
of 80 percent but is it classifying
correctly
a confusion Matrix represents a table
layout of the different outcomes of
prediction
and results of a classification problem
and helps visualize its outcomes
and so you see here we have our simple
chart predicted and actual the confusion
Matrix helps us identify the correct
predictions of a model for different
individual classes as well as the errors
so you'll see here that the values
predicted by our classifier are along
the rows this is what we're going to
guess it is or CL our model is guessing
what this is based on its training so
we've already trained the model to guess
whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value that's
supposed to be
people who can speak English will be
classified as positives so because they
have a remember zero one do you speak
English yes no and you could extend this
that they might have do you speak French
do you speak whatever language is and so
you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these people who cannot speak
English will be classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so yeah zero ones
the number of times are actual positive
values are equal to predicted positive
values gives us true positive TP the
number of times are actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative TN
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
FP
and you'll see when you're working with
these a lot you know memorizing that
it's false positive you can easily
figure out what that is and pretty soon
you're just looking at the FP or the TP
depending on what you're working on and
the numbers times our model wrongly
predicts positive values as negatives
and gives us a false negative FP
now I'm going to do a quick step out
here
let's say you're working in the medical
and we're talking about cancer
do you really want a bunch of false
negatives
you want zero under false negative
so when we look at this confusion Matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have twenty percent
false positives because they go in and
test it in zero false negatives
let's say it might be true if you're
working on uh say a car driving is this
a safe place for the car to go well you
really don't want any false positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on this chart suddenly has huge value we
were talking about spam email how many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in that you want
to be a a true a false negative you
don't want it to go in the spam folder
likewise you want to get as much of the
spam out of there but you don't want to
miss anything really important
confusion Matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier there are four main
metrics accuracy precision recall and F1
score the F1 score is the one I usually
hear the most and accuracy is usually
what you put on your chart when you're
sending in front of the shareholders how
accurate is it people understand
accuracy
F1 score is a little bit more on the
math side and so you got to be a little
careful when you're quoting F1 scores in
the when you're sitting there with all
the shareholders because a lot of them
will just glaze over so confusion Matrix
metrics are performance measures which
help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values it tells us how often our
classifier is right it is the sum of all
True Values divided by the total values
and this makes sense uh again it's one
of those things
I don't want to you know it depends on
what you're looking for are you looking
for uh not to miss any spam mails are
you looking to drive down the road and
not run anybody over
Precision is used to calculate the
model's ability to classify positive
values correctly it answers the question
when the model predicts a positive value
how often is it right it is the true
positive divided by the total number of
predicted positive values again in this
one depends on what project you're
working on whether this is what you're
going to be focusing on
uh so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often does the model actually
predict the correct positive values
it is a true positive divided by the
total number of actual positive values
and then your F1 score it is the
harmonic mean of recall and precision it
is useful when you need to take both
precision and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
Matrix derived from two different
classifier to figure out which one
performs better we can find the
confusion Matrix for both of them
and you can see we're back to uh does it
classify whether they can speak English
or are non-speaker they speak some they
don't I know the English language and so
we put these two uh confusion matrixes
out here we can go ahead and do the math
behind that we can look up the accuracy
that's a tpn plus TN over the TF plus TN
plus FP plus FN and so we get an
accuracy of 0.8125
and we have a Precision if you do the
Precision which is your TP truth
positive over TP plus FP
uh we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your TP over TP
plus FN and then of course your F1 score
which is two times Precision times
recall over Precision plus recall
and we get the 0.857
and if we do that with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one we
want to use for whatever reason we might
go ahead and compute the same things we
have our accuracy our precision and our
recall and our F1 score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy because that's
really what we're interested in is uh
how many people are we able to classify
as being able to speak English I really
don't want to know if I'm you know I I
really don't want to know if they're
non-speakers
um I'd rather Miss 10 people speaking
English instead of 15. and so you can
see from these charts we probably go
with the first model because it does a
better job guessing who speaks English
and has a higher accuracy because in
this case that is what we're looking for
so uh with that we'll go ahead and pull
up a demo so you can see what this looks
like in the python uh setup and in the
actual coding for this we'll go into
Anaconda Navigator if you're not
familiar with Anaconda it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos
and for quick development as a data
scientist I just love the package now if
you're going to do something heavier
lifting there's some limitations with
anaconda and with the setup but in
general you can do just about anything
in here with your python
and for this we'll go with Jupiter
notebook Jupiter lab is the same as
Jupiter notebook you'll see they now
have integration with pi charm if you
work in pycharm uh certainly there's a
lot of other Integrations that Anaconda
has and we've opened up
um we simply learned files I work on and
create a new file called confusion
Matrix demo and the first thing we want
to note is the data we're working with
here I've opened it up in a word pad or
notepad or whatever
uh you can see it's got a row of
headers comma separated and then all the
data going down below
and then I save this in the same file so
I don't have to remember what path I'm
working on uh of course if you have your
data separated and you're working with a
lot of data you probably want to put it
into a different folder or file
depending on what you're doing
and the first thing we want to do is go
ahead and import our tools we're going
to use the pandas that's our data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review Panda's
data frame going to Simply learn you can
pull up the pandas data frame
tutorial on there
and then we're going to use uh the
scikip framework which is all denoted as
sklearn and I can just pull this in you
can see here's the scikit dash learn.org
with the stable version that you can
import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model that's our actual
machine learning model we're using and
then with this core this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score the confusion Matrix and
the classifier report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here so
we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read CSV
and then just because we're in jupyter
Notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here a lot of times we'll
actually let me just do this I prefer to
do the just the head of the date or the
top part
and you can see we have age sex I'm not
sure what CP stands for test BPS
cholesterol so a lot of different
measurements if you were in this domain
you'd want to know what all these
different measurements mean
I don't want to focus on that too much
because when we're talking about data
science a lot of times you have no idea
what the data means if you've ever
looked up the breast cancer measurement
it's just a bunch of measurements and
numbers uh unless you're a doctor you're
gonna have no idea what those
measurements mean
but if it's your specialty in your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create Y and it's
going to we're going to set it equal to
the Target so here's our Target value
here
and it's either one or zero
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with one zero true false what do
you have you have a classifier
and then our X is going to be uh
everything except for the Target so
we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals one remember that's
columns versus the index for rows X is
equal to zero would would give you an
error but you would drop like row two
and then we'll go ahead and just print
that out so you can see what we're
looking at and uh here we have Y data X
data and you can see from the X data we
have the X head and we can go ahead and
just do print
the Y head data
and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far if there's a confusion
in there go back and rewind the tape and
review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into our X train X test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data before we do the
scalar and the reason is is that you
want the scalar on the training data to
be set on the training data data or fit
to it but not on the test data think of
this as being out in the field you're
not you could actually alter your
results uh so it's always important to
do make sure whatever you do to the
training data or whatever fit you're
doing is always done on the training not
on the test and then we want to go ahead
and scale the data
now we are working with linear
regression model and I'll mention this
here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
so some sometimes you don't need to
scale when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact
uh but we're going to go ahead and take
here's our X train X test y train y test
we create our scalar we go ahead and
scale uh the scale is going to fit the X
train
and then we're going to go ahead and
take our X train and transform it and
then we also need to take our X test and
transform it based on the scale on here
so that our X is now between that nice
minus one to one and so this is all our
pre data setup
and
hopefully all of that looks fairly
familiar to you if you've done a number
of our other classes and you're up to
the setup on here
and then we want to go ahead and do is
create our model and we're going to use
a logistic regression model
and from the logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our X
train and Y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
and let's just go ahead and run that and
so now we are we actually have like our
X test and our prediction so if you
remember from
our Matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction and how those
compare
and if I take us back up here you're
going to notice that we imported the
accuracy score the confusion Matrix and
the classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and I did mention it's going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic Mass standard
regression models and I'd have to look
it up for the logistic regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases uh but if you're in a
neural network and you're there's a lot
of other different setups then you
really want to take this and fit that on
there
and so we can go in and do the accuracy
uh and this is if you remember correctly
we were looking at the accuracy
with the English speaking so this is
saying our accuracy as to whether this
person is I believe this is the heart
data set
um
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict the person is
going to have a heart condition
or the one as it comes up with the zero
one on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent uh being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion Matrix and let me just do
that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here
um here's our 25
uh
prediction uh correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide I'll
just bring this over so it's a nice
visual we have our true positive false
positive
so we had 25 which were true that it
said hey this person is going to be high
risk at heart and we had four that were
still high risk that has said were false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85 out of 29 people
it was correct on 25 of them and so uh
here's our accuracy score we were just
looking at that our accuracy is your
true positive and your true negative
over all of them so how true is it and
there was our accuracy coming up here
0.85 and then we have our nice Matrix
generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
Matrix we had going for that from the
slide and this starts to let's just
start asking questions at this point
um so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at this data here and
saying well
is this good enough is uh this number of
people and hopefully you'd have a much
larger data set in my is my confusion
Matrix showing for the true positive and
false positive is that acceptable for
what we're doing uh and of course if
you're going to put together whatever
data you're putting out you might want
to separate the true negative false
positive false negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion Matrix and then of course the
Ravel part lets you set that up so you
can just split that right up into a nice
Tuple and the final thing we want to
show you here in the coding on this part
is the confusion Matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the Matrix equals classification report
the Y test and the predict
and then we're going to take that
classification report and go ahead and
print that out
and you can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average your weighted average you have
your Precision your recall your F1 score
and your support all in one window so
you can start looking at this data and
saying oh okay our precision's at 0.83
uh 0.87 for getting a a positive and
0.83 for the negative site for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use and
when we're looking at heart attack
prediction we're only looking at one
aspect what's the chances of this person
having a heart attack or not you might
have something where we went back to the
languages maybe you also want to know
whether they speak English or Hindi or
French and you can see right here that
we can now take our confusion Matrix and
just expand it as big as we need to
depending on how many different
classifiers we're working on decision
tree important terms before we dive in
further we need to look at some basic
terms we need to have some definitions
to go with our decision tree in the
different parts we're going to be using
we'll start with entropy entropy is a
measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math and how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node Leaf node
carries a classification or the decision
so it's a final end at the bottom the
decision node has two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and finally you
have the root node the topmost decision
node is known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and there are of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animal the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math you don't really have to memorize
this math and just be aware that it's
there and this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case let's say it's the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight log base two one over
eight and plus two over eight of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we plug
that into our computer or calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow
yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to decreased
considerably however we still need some
splitting at both the branches to attain
an entropy value equal to zero so we
decide to split both the nodes using
height as the condition since every
Branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes of the Tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separate
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the data set with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to be pay their
loan or not for this bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the Jupiter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function that's needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and I'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and this
can be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here I've
opened it up in the open Office calc
which is pretty much the same as Excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting the data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data.head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
our print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data and we always start with zero
so we have five lines we have zero one
two three four instead of one two three
four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data and Y is going to
be the answer or the target you can look
at it source and Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines in the database so it's all the
data and the second one says we're only
going to look at columns one through
five remember always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not so we want
to start with one if we go back up here
that's the initial payment and it goes
all the way through the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case when we set
the clf entropical decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play Within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this tutorial able to go through all of
these and how they work but we're
working on entropy that's one of the
options we've added that it's completely
a random state of 100 so 100 percent and
we have a max depth of three now the max
depth if you remember above when we were
doing the different graphs of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops and then we have
minimal samples of leaves is five so
it's going to have at least five leaves
at the end so I'll have at least three
splits I'll have no more than three
layers and at least five in leaves with
the final result at the bottom now that
we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go ahead and apply it
and see what that looks like so let's go
ahead and make a prediction and see what
that looks like we're going to paste our
predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the SK learn modules that
they're different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case so we need
to test out the data and just see how
good our sample is how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
is it works as a command line for python
we can simply put the why predict en to
print it I could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
a decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not how does a random Forest
work as a whole so to begin our random
Forest classifier let's say we already
have built three trees and we're going
to start with the first tree that looks
looks like this just like we did in the
example this tree looks at the diameter
if it's greater than or equal to 3 it's
true otherwise it's false so one side
goes to the smaller diameter one side
goes to larger diameter and if the color
is orange it's going to go to the right
true we're using oranges now instead of
limits and if it's red it's going to go
to the left false we build a second tree
very similar but split differently
instead of the first one being split by
a diameter this one when they created it
if you look at that first Bowl it has a
lot of red objects so it says is the
color red because that's going to bring
our entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one it's going to drop
the entropy the quickest and as you can
see it splits it into true if it goes
false and they've added another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false it goes off to the left if it's
true it goes off to the right let's go
ahead and bring these three trees you
can see them all in one image so this
would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe as a person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is a color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value it say true and go to the
right tree two classifies it as cherries
is a color equal red is the shape of
circle true it is a circle so this would
look at it and say oh that's a cherry
and then we go to the other classifier
and it says is the diameter equal one
well that's false does it grow in the
summer true so it goes down and looks at
as oranges so how does this random
Forest work the first one says it's an
orange the second one said it was a
cherry and the third one says it's an
orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it I don't know about
you but I'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and I did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
oh this is the exciting part as we roll
up our sleeves and actually look at some
python coating before we start the
python coding we need to go ahead and
create a problem statement wonder what
species of Iris do these flowers belong
to let's try to predict the species of
the flowers using machine learning in
Python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and Implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into Python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case I'm going to be using the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter note
book and I've already opened up a new
page for Python 3 code and I'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets import load Iris now
this isn't the actual data this is just
the module that allows us to bring in
the data the load Iris and the iris is
so popular it's been around since 1936
when Ronald Fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import our random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules and these are probably
the most commonly used modules in Python
and data science with any of the other
modules that we bring in and one is
going to be pandas we're going to import
pandas as PD p is the common term used
for pandas and pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where when
you create a pandas data frame it looks
like an Excel spreadsheet and you'll see
that in a minute when we start digging
deeper into the code panda is just
wonderful because it plays nice with all
the other modules in there and then we
have numpy which is our numbers Python
and the numbers python allows us to do
different mathematical sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our NP and we're going to go
ahead and Seed the randomness with it
with zero so
np.random.seed is seating that as zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because I need to make sure I have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember I told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and and here we go
we've gone ahead and run the Imports now
I'm going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the IRS
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable Iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the DF to
Define data frame
and that's going to equal PD and if you
remember that's pandas as PD so that's
our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data and columns equals
Irish feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our DF has created what looks like
an Excel spreadsheet and in this Excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and I'm going to go print
I'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print olivirus
and see what that looks like
so when I print all a virus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length simple width
petal length pedal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names the target names which is
further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the Head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and Panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the panda
dataframe dot head it'll print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have them
in this case we have the column header
set to Iris features and in here you'll
see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in Python
most arrays always start at zero so when
you look at the first five it's going to
be zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our IRS
data imported into a data frame let's
take a look at the next piece of code in
here and so in this section here of the
code we're going to take a look at the
Target and let's go ahead and get this
into our notebook this piece of code so
we can discuss it a little bit more in
detail so here we are in our jupyter
notebook I'm going to put the code in
here and before I run it I want to look
at a couple things going on so we have
DF species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where I
have DF species in Brackets which is the
key code for creating another column and
here we have iris.target now these are
both in the pandas setup on here so in
pandas we can do either one I could have
just as easily done Iris and then in
Brackets Target depending on what I'm
working on both are acceptable let's go
ahead and run this code and see how this
changes and what we've done is we've
added the target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our our neural
network to look for these this different
data and know what a setosa is or a Vera
color which we'll see in just a minute
or virginica those are the three that
are in there and now we're going to add
one more column I know we're organizing
all this data over and over again it's
kind of fun there's a lot of ways to
organize it what's nice about putting
everything onto one data frame is I can
then do a printout and it shows me
exactly what I'm looking at and I'll
show you that where you where that's
different where you can alter that and
do it slightly differently but let's go
ahead and put this into our script up to
that now and here we go we're going to
put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it DF remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals NP remember
that stands for numpy DOT random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length DF comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take 75 percent of the data roughly
because there's a Randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 percent we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def.head
which prints the first five rows and
we've added a column is train at the end
and so we're going to take that we're
going to create two variables we're
going to create two new data frames
one's called train one's called test 75
percent in train 25 in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing DF our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it and if DF is trained equals
true
that's going to go in the train and if
DF is trained equals false it goes in
the test and so when I run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and let's make it readable to
humans I don't know about you but I hate
looking at zeros and ones so let's start
with the features and let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when I
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing I want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's Jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the a terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when I run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about Jupiter notebooks
is I'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to PD dot factorize train species of
zero so let's break this down just a
little bit we have our pandas right here
PD factorize what is factorize doing I'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is and why we're looking at the group
zero on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this and we created this whole
column here for species
and then it has cytosis cytosis cytosis
cytosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and Vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end and then species is just that
column factorize goes in there and looks
at the fact that there's only three of
them so when I run this you'll see that
y generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go we have two
lines of code oh my goodness that was a
lot of work to get to two lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into our full
script that we're running and let's
paste this in here and let's take a look
and see what this is we have we're
creating a variable clf and we're going
to set this equal to the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals two if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf dot fit
so we're fitting we're training it we
are actually creating our random Forest
classifier right here this is a code
that does everything and we're going to
take our training set remember we kept
our test off to the side and we're going
to take our training set with the
features and then we're going to go
ahead and put that in and here's our
Target the Y so the Y is 0 1 and 2 that
we just created and the features is the
actual data going in that we put into
the training set let's go ahead and run
that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random Forest
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random State
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there you would really have to
dig deep to find out all these the
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like Max
features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there is just
going to automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process in
leaf nodes that's the end notes remember
we had the fruit and we're talking about
the leaf nodes like I said there's a lot
in this we're looking at a lot of stuff
here so you might have in this case
there's probably only think three leaf
nodes maybe four you might have
thousands of leaf nodes at which point
you do need to put a cap on that and say
okay you can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this and that really is
what most of these are about is limiting
the process and making sure we don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here again we're not
going to go over all of them warm start
equals false alarm start is if you're
programming it one piece at a time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually to train this particular
Learning Tree and again like I said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the SK learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our Target
y so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the Versa color and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features and I always kind of like
to know what it is I am looking at so
real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple length sepal width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing so
what features looks like this is just
playing with the with pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test it then
takes those columns and creates a panda
data frames from those columns and in
this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2 and we're going to put
those in and we're going to predict what
our new Forest classifier is going to
come up with and this is what it
predicts it predicts uh zero zero zero
one two one one two two two and and
again this is the flower type setosa
virginica and Versa color so now that
we've taken our test features let's
explore that let's see exactly what that
data means to us so the first thing we
can do with our predicts is we can
actually generate a different prediction
model when I say different we're going
to view it differently it's not that the
data itself is different so let's take
this next piece of code and put it into
our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf DOT
predict probability so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was what 27
you'll see right down here that this
generates a much larger field on the
probability and let's take a look and
see what that looks like and what that
means
so when we do the predict underscore
praba for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did this is the predictors the
first one is predicting a one for setosa
it predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a zero for Versa color and so
on and so on and so on and let's uh you
know what I'm going to change this just
a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5 and so if
we're going to vote and we have two
equal votes it's going to go with the
first one so it says setosa gets zero
votes virginica gets 0.5 votes Versa
color gets 0.5 votes but let's just go
with the virginica since these two are
equal and so on and so on down the list
you can see how they vary on here so now
we've looked at both how to do a basic
predict of the features and we've looked
at the predict probability let's see
what's next on here so now we want to go
ahead and start mapping names for the
plants we want to attach names so that
it makes a little more sense for us and
this we're going to do in these next two
steps we're going to start by setting up
our predictions and mapping them to the
name so let's see what that looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's Iris
dot Target names
and if you remember correctly this was
the the names that we've been talking
about this whole time the Sentosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just hit a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that Returns the
zeros the ones in the twos and then
we're going to set that equal to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable and when I run
this
hit distributes and it comes out as an
array and the array is setosis cytosis
cytosis cytosa we're only looking at the
first five we could actually do let's do
the first 25 just so we can see a little
bit more on there and you'll see that it
starts mapping it to all the different
flower types the Versa color and the
virginica in there and let's see how
this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it and let's talk about both these
sections of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and I went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosis cytosis cytosis
cytosis that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species I remember I could have
just done
test.species.head and you'll see it says
cytosis cytosis cytosa and they match so
the first one is what our forest is
doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our Jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then I'm going to because I'm on
the jupyter notebook I can do a control
minus you can see the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here we're
going to create in pandas remember PD
stands for pandas and we're doing a
cross tab this function takes two sets
of data and creates a chart out of them
so when I run it you'll get a nice chart
down here and we have the predicted
species
so across the top you'll see the satosha
versus color virginica and the actual
species sistosa versicolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versicolor where they meet and you have
virginica where they meet and they're
meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree so this is the number of
accurate predictions so in this case it
equals 30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12
you get 30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor this is
inaccurate so now we have two two
inaccurate predictions and 30 accurate
predictions so I will say that the model
accuracy is 93 that's just 30 divided by
32 and if we multiply by a hundred we
can say that it is 93 percent accurate
so we have a 93 accuracy with our model
I did want to add one more quick thing
in here on our scripting before we wrap
it up so let's flip back on over to my
script in here we're going to take this
line of code from up above I don't know
if you remember it but predicts equals
the iris dot Target underscore names so
we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features but you
know we're not just testing it we want
to actually deploy it so at this point I
would go ahead and change this and this
is an array of arrays this is really
important when you're running these to
know that
so you need the double brackets and they
could actually create data maybe let's
let's just do two flowers so maybe I'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then I actually want to see what the
answer is so let's go ahead and type in
preds and print that out and when I run
this
you'll see that I've now predicted two
flowers so maybe I measured in my front
yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since I put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this today we're going
to cover the K nearest neighbors that
refer to as k n n and KN is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
Incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need knnn what is k n how do
we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog a little kid looking over
there and watching the black cat cross
their path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although I do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate their
sharpness of the claws how sharp are
their claws and we can evaluate the
length of the ears and we can usually
sort out cats from dogs based on even
those two characteristics now tell me if
it is a cat or a dog an odd question
usually little kids no cats and dogs by
now unless you live a place where
there's not many cats or dogs so if we
look at the sharpness of the claws the
length of the ears and we can see that
the cat has a smaller ears and sharper
claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and goes
in the cat group because KNN is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using kn n classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is KNN what is the k
n algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or it's not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how his
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we've gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and K N is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals
five we'll talk about K in just a minute
a day point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know k equals five I
mean that's what is the value we put in
there I said we're going to talk about
it how do we choose the factor K and N
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of K is a
process called parameter tuning and is
important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this as a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around it you can see as the K changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these vectors
that's the face you get he's like oh my
gosh you say choose the right K did I
set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias in
One Direction or the other and in terms
of knnn the number of K if you choose it
too low the bias is based on it's just
too noises it's it's right next to a
couple things and it's going to pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your K is too big then
it's going to take forever to process so
you're going to run into processing
issues and resource issues so what we do
the most common use and there's other
options for choosing K is to use the
square root of n so it is a total number
of values you have you take the square
root of it in most cases you also if
it's an even number so if you're using
uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knnn we can use knnn when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class we have like underweight
140 23 Hello Kitty normal that's pretty
confusing we have a high variety of data
coming in so it's very noisy and that
would cause an issue data set is small
so we're usually working with smaller
data sets where you might get into a gig
of data if it's really clean it doesn't
have a lot of noise because K N is a
lazy learner I.E it doesn't learn a
discriminative function from the
training set so it's very lazy so if you
have very complicated data and you have
a large amount of it you're not going to
use the KNN but it's really great to get
a place to start even with large data
you can sort out a small sample and get
an idea of what that looks like using
the knnn and also just using for smaller
data sets k n works really good how does
a k n algorithm work consider a data set
having two variables height in
centimeters and weight in kilograms and
each point is classified as normal or
underweight so we see right here we have
two variables you know true false are
either normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using k n n so
if we have new data coming in this says
57 kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance D equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus B squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're Computing the third Edge
since we we know the X side and the Y
side let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is the
square root of 170 minus 167 squared
plus 57 minus 51 squared which is about
6.7 and distance 2 is about 13 and
distance 3 is about 13.4 similarly we
will calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do and it's actually
pretty quick for a computer and it's not
a really complicated Mass you can just
see how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where X1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest name neighbors
now let's calculate the nearest neighbor
at k equals three and we can see the
three closest neighbors puts them at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what you know we're
just voting normal normal three votes
for normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knnn positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in Python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it well that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the knnn and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768. it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer shooter I can
look at it I can manipulate it and it's
not going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what IDE I'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but I like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the Anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
Jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the Anaconda Navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home I can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 I have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if I
go under environments I can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where you can install different
packages so if I click on that button
and open the terminal I can then use a
simple pip install to install different
packages I'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and I've already
you know kind of like the old cooking
shows I've already prepared a lot of my
stuff so we don't have to wait for it to
launch because it takes a few minutes
for it to open up a browser window in
this case I'm going it's going to open
up Chrome because that's my default that
I use and since the script is pre-done
you'll see I have a number of windows
open up at the top the one we're working
in and since we're working on the KNN
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not let's go and put that
title in there and I'm also going to go
up here and click on Cell actually we
want to go ahead and first insert a cell
below and then I'm going to go back up
to the top cell and I'm going to change
the cell type to markdown that means
this is not going to run as python it's
a markdown language so if I run this
first one it comes up in nice big
letters which is kind of nice remind us
what we're working on and by now you
should be familiar with doing all of our
Imports we're going to import the pandas
as PD import numpy is NP pandas is the
pandas data frame and numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our Imports so even brought
in our pandas are numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our train test split by now
you should be familiar with splitting
the data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between
-1 and 1. and then the actual tool this
is the K neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
Matrix our F1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read CSV that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder I just put in the
same folder where my IPython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick Links of the data set
that is a simple python on command Len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line links.dataset in
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there if you
put a bunch of these in a row you know
the data set one head data set two head
it only prints out the last one so I
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame pandas
data frame doing it this way it doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the Run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure sure all the way to H and then
the outcome on the end and we're going
to do a couple things in this next step
we're going to create a list of columns
where we can't have zero there's no such
thing as zero skin thickness or zero
blood pressure zero glucose any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
Factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the N A but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals datasetc column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the Nan num pnan is
what that stands for is none it doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the 0 in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead hope they just
didn't get the data the next thing we
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column dot mean where we
skip in A's we can do that and that is a
pandas command there the skip n a so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the npnan with the
means why did we do that and we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replace 0
and Skip anything where except you can
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you can see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average person so if we
don't know what it is if they did not
get the data and the data is missing one
of the tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything in the first few lines just not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with the printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the one shows you can see I skipped a
bunch in the middle because that's what
it does we have too many lines in
Jupiter notebook he'll skip a few and go
on to the next in a data set let me go
and remove this and we'll just zero out
that and of course before we do any
processing before proceeding any further
we need to split the data set into our
train and testing data that way we have
something to train it with and something
to test it on and you're going to notice
we did a little something here with the
pandas database code there we go my
drawing tool we've added in this right
here off the data set and what this says
is that the first one in pandas this is
from the PD pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at zero columns 0 To 8. Remember column
no this is actually zero to seven it
doesn't include the last one and then we
go down here to Y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column eight and you can do it this way
with this particular note and then if
you remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the SK learn right
there and we simply put in our X and our
y we're going to do random State equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seed
it that's a seed number I think the
default is one when you seed it I'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 percent of the data and
put it aside so that we can test it
later that's all that is and again we're
going to run it not very exciting so far
we haven't had any printout other than
to look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual running of our k n we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in the standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
-1 and 1. that's what that standard
scalar does keeps its standardized and
we only want to fit the scalar with the
training set but we want to make sure
the testing set is the X test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same so here we go with our
standard scalar we're going to call it
SC underscore X for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our X train
equals SC underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the X
train variable and then our X test we're
also going to transform it so we've
trained and transformed the X train and
then the X test isn't part of that
training it isn't part of that of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to run this if you look at
this we've now gone through these steps
all three of them we've taken care of
replacing our zeros for key columns it
shouldn't be zero and we replace that
with the means of those columns that way
that they fit right in with our data
models we've come down here we split the
data so now we have our test data and
our training data and then we've taken
and we've scaled the data so all of our
data going in now no we don't TR we
don't train the Y part the Y train and Y
test that never has to be trained it's
only the data going in that's what we
want to train in there then Define the
model using K Nabors classifier and fit
the train data in the model so we do all
that data prep and you can see down here
we're only going to have a couple lines
of code where we're actually building
our model and training it that's one of
the cool things about Python and how far
we've come it's such an exciting time to
be in machine learning because there's
so many automated tools let's see before
we do this let's do a quick Links of and
let's do y we want yeah let's just do
length of Y and we get 768 and if we
import math we do math dot square root
let's do y train there we go it's
actually supposed to be X train before
we do this let's go ahead and do import
math and do math square root length of Y
test and when I run that we get 12.409 I
want to see show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here that's one of
the reasons I love Jupiter notebook
because you can flip around and do all
kinds of things on the fly so we'll go
ahead and put in our classifier we're
creating our classifier now and it's
going to be the K neighbors classifier
and neighbors equal 11. remember we did
12 minus 1 for 11. so we have an odd
number of neighbors P equals 2 because
we're looking for is it are they
diabetic or not and we're using the
euclidean metric there are other means
of measuring the distance you can do
like square square means values all
kinds of measure this but the euclidean
is the most common one and it works
quite well it's important to evaluate
the model let's use the confusion Matrix
to do that and we're going to use the
confusion Matrix wonderful tool and then
we'll jump into the F1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix why
test why predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the Y predicted which would be
your title up here we could do let's
just do pred
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and I believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion Matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the F1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our F1 score the F1 takes into
account both sides of the balance of
false positives where if we go ahead and
just do the accuracy account and that's
what most people think of is it looks at
just how many we got right out of how
many we got wrong so a lot of people
when you're a data scientist and you're
talking to other data scientists they're
going to ask you what the F1 score the F
score is if you're talking to the
general public or the decision makers in
the business they're going to ask what
the accuracy is and the accuracy is
always better than the F1 score but the
F1 scores more telling it lets us know
that there's more false positives than
we would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an SK learn and running the k n
n the K nearest neighbor on it so we
have created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or the very East whether
they should go get a checkup and have
their glucose checked regularly or not
the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent it tells us it is a pretty fair
fit in the model so far so clear but a
question should be coming up we have our
sample data set but instead of looking
like this what if it looked like this
where we have two sets of data but one
of them occurs in the middle of another
set you can see here where we have the
blue and the yellow and then blue again
on the other side of our data line in
this data set we can't use a hyperplane
so when you see data like this it's
necessary to move away from a 1D view of
the data to a two-dimensional view of
the data and for the transformation we
use what's called a kernel function the
kernel function will take the 1D input
and transfer it to a two-dimensional
output as you can see in this picture
here the 1D when transferred to a
two-dimensional makes it very easy to
draw a line between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2D to a 3D
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support Vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two Dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional base one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
I've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or Lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or it's going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support Vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some Python Programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo we have the young child going
dad is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father's hittinger is
thinking how can I turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support Vector machine segregate the two
groups I don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements in data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and I'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data I talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup I like to
use the Anaconda jupyter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the Anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupyter notebook with python
we're using python3 I believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and you'd have to look at
the SK learn and make sure if you're
using a 2X version an earlier version
let's go and put our code in there and
one of the things I like about the
jupyter notebook is then go up to view
and I'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is edited
in in this case I'm using Google Chrome
Explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor although anyone any like I
said any editor will work now the first
step is going to be our Imports and
we're going to import four different
parts the first two I want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as NP and matplot Library dot Pi plot as
PLT now these are very standardized
Imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and I'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use NP for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has you do need the NP for the
sklearn module but the matplot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to I'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the
sklearn.datasets.samples generator
import make blobs and I told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the SK learning to make
up data I personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as I work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length instead we're just going to make
up some data and that's what that make
blobs is It's a Wonderful tool if you're
ready to test your your setup and you're
not sure about what data you're going to
put in there you can create this blob
and it makes it real easy to use and
finally we have our actual svm the
sklearn import svm on line 3 e so that
covers all our Imports we're going to
create remember I used the make blobs to
create data and we're going to create a
capital x and a lowercase y equals make
blobs in samples equals 40. so we're
going to make 40 lines of data it's
going to have two centers with a random
State equals 20. so each each group is
going to have 20 different pieces of
data in it and the way that lux is that
we'll have under X an X Y plane so I
have two numbers under X and Y will be 0
1. that's the two different centers so
we have yes or no in this case alligator
a crocodile that's what that represents
and then I told you that the actual SK
learner the svm is in two lines of code
and we see it right here with clf equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and I set
SQL to 1 although in this example since
we are not regularizing the data because
we want to be very clear and easy to see
I went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very Sim simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit X comma Y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and I'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements in this case we
have like the width and length of the
snout and I did say I was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see PLT that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
I have the capital x and then in
brackets I have a colon comma zero
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an air error in
a python array you have to have that in
a numpy array it turns out that our make
blobs returns a numpy array and this
notation is great because what it means
is the first part is the colon means
we're going to do all the rows that's
all the data in our blob we created
under capital x and then the second
Point has a comma zero we're only going
to take the first value and then if you
notice we do the same thing but we're
going to take the second value remember
we always start with zero and then one
so we have column 0 and column one and
you can look at this as our X Y plots
the first one is the X plot and the
second one is the Y plot so the first
one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10
and then the second one X of the one is
the four five six seven eight nine ten
going up the left hand side s equals 30
is just the size of the dot so we can
see them instead little tiny dots and
then C map equals plt.cm dot paired and
you'll also see the C equals y That's
the color we're using 2 colors zero one
and that's why we get the nice blue and
the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile now you can
see here that we did this the actual fit
was done in two lines of code a lot of
times there'll be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case I am giving it a width and
length three four and a with the length
five six and note that I put the data as
a set of brackets and then I have the
brackets inside and the reason I do that
is because when we're looking at data
it's designed to process a large amount
of data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case I'm processing two lines and
then I'm just going to print and you'll
see clf.predict new data so the clf and
the dot predict part is going to give us
an answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the 3 4 is going to be on the
one side and the 5 6 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as an
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dug in and see what's going on
behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like so the next step is to
dig in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes and also put that in a
nice pretty graph we're going to spend
more work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and I'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and I'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our Jupiter notebook
before I scroll down to a new line I
want you to notice line 13 it has Plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and I'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here our new
section one two three and four is the
same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're going to fit the values on our svm
and then we're going to plot scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code well when you do
the plot show that blanks out what's in
the plot so once I've done this Plot
show I have to reload that data now we
could do this simply by removing it up
here re-running it and then coming down
here and then we wouldn't have to rerun
these first four lines of code now in
this it doesn't matter too much and
you'll see the plot show us down here
and then removed right there on line
five I'll go ahead and just delete that
out of there because we don't want to
blank out our screen we want to move on
to the next setup so we can go ahead and
just skip the first four lines because
we did that before and let's take a look
at the ax equals
plt.gca now right now we're actually
spending a lot of time just graphing
that's all we're doing here okay so this
is how we display a nice graph with our
results and our data ax is very standard
used variable when you're talking about
PLT and it's just setting it to that
axis the last axis in the PLT they can
get very confusing if you're working
with many different layers of data on
the same graph and this makes it very
easy to reference the ax so this
reference is looking at the PLT that we
created and we already mapped out our
two blobs on and then we want to know
the limits so we want to know how big
the graph is we can find out the X limit
and the Y limit simply with the get X
limit and get y limit commands which is
part of our matplot library and then
we're going to create a grid and you'll
see down here we have we've set the
variable XX equal to mp.line Space X
limit 0 x limit 1 comma 30 and we've
done the same thing for the y space and
then we're going to go in here and we
create a mesh grid and this is a numpy
command so we're back to our numbers
python let's go through what these numpy
commands mean with the line space and
the mesh grid we've taken XX small s x x
equals NP line space and we have our X
limit 0 and our X limit 1 and we're
going to create 30 points on it and
we're going to do the same thing for the
y-axis now this has nothing to do with
our evaluation it's all we're doing is
we're creating a grid head of data and
so we're creating a set of points
between 0 and the X limit we're creating
30 points and the same thing with the Y
and then the mesh grid Loops those all
together so it forms a nice grid so if
we were going to do this say between the
limit 0 and 10 and do 10 points we would
have a 0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and
so on you can just imagine a point at
Each corner of one of those boxes and
the mesh grid combines them all so we
take the YY and the XX we created and
creates the full grid and we've set that
grid into the YY coordinates and the x x
coordinates now remember we're working
with numbi and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being X comma 1 you know X comma Y
and then X2 comma Y2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital y y and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array X Y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value Z and the
Z equals the clf that's our that's our
support Vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a DOT
decision function and we're going to put
the X Y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that X Y in
there that data we're going to reshape
it and you'll see that we have the XX
dot shape in here this literally takes
the XX resets it up connected to the Y
and the Z value lets us know whether it
is the left hand side it's going to
generate three different values as Z
value does and it'll tell us whether
that data is a support Vector to the
left the hyperplane in the middle or the
support Vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separate it
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our matplot library where we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
Contour Capital XX capital y y these
have been reshaped to fit those lines Z
is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals K
and I told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alpha is just makes it kind of
see-through so it's only 0.5 of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line Styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be Dash dashed lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dashed line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf Dot support vectors we are
looking at column 0 and column one and
then again we have the S equals 100 so
we're going to make them larger and the
line width equals one face colors equals
none let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
Four Points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this Hands-On example
will help you to encounter any support
Vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth regularization
in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data understanding linear regression
bias and variance what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and underfitting
what does that mean and what is
regularization and then we'll do a quick
Hands-On demo to take a look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about what
is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called Data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go a little deeper on there so
we might have in this case just a two
Dimensions we have an efficiency of the
car and we have the distance traveled in
one thousand kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship very specifically linear
means line uh the line used to represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have a linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with uh how linear
regression Works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car versus the
distance traveled and you can see this
nice straight line drawn through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane it gets a little more complicated
with multiple variables but they all
come down to this linear kind of drawing
a line through your data and finding
what fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example let's
say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the cells of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw L1 and L2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claimed to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line L1 and each
data point and at them all and find the
mean distance
and I want you to think about that when
we
Square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function and we talk about loss how
far off are we that's what we're really
talking about what did we miss and we
have a positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we Square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as MSE if I look in a
code and I'm going through my python
code and I see MSE I know that's a mean
squared error and we take all the dotted
lines and we calculated this error and
we add them all together and then we
average it or find the means
and in this case they ran a demo on this
and it was a
1127.27 for our L1 line
now we find the loss function for line
L2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397.
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for L1 than L2 hence L1 is
the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes we're going to keep
guessing and get as close as we can to
find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite to calculate this and
figure out which one's the best and the
mean square error is one of the better
fits to doing for doing this and most
commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance very important terms to know in
machine learning and with linear
regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
bias you can think is very generalized
where variance is very specific
uh and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and oversimplify the model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you oversimplify it
so much you're going to miss your local
uh if if you have like a really good fit
you're going to miss it you're you're
going to just kind of guess what the
average is and that's what your answer
is going to be
with variants a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data and I
want you to think about this
um when we're talking about a bias the
error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average we're not really fitting it
close
with variants we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it may have to be red because you had so
many red pictures so if it has if it's
an 18 wheeler it has to be red if it's
blue then it has to be a bicycle that's
the kind of variance we're talking about
where it picks up on something and it it
cannot get the right answer unless it
gets a very specific data and we see
that so that as you're testing it your
models and you've programmed it you got
to look for how I trained it what is
coming out and if it's not if it's not
looking good on either bias or if it's
not looking good on the training or on
the test data then you're bias then your
biasing your data if it really looks
good on the training data then that's
going to be your variance you've
overfitted the data and those are very
important things to know when you are
building your models in regression of
any kind or any kind of setup for
predicting
so in dark games if all the data Fawn a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall in
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no two points that
might have that you know y might have
two different answers because uh if the
wind blows a certain way
um and your efficiency of your car maybe
you have a headwind so your car might
alter how efficient it is as it goes and
so there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance what's you know the this is
it's going to be exactly this there
can't be any you can't be the same speed
or the same car and have a slightly
different efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not cleaned and
contains noise garbage values in it you
can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's the source of the data
maybe they use in medical different
measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus Hospital
b or even off of machine a and machine B
that's testing something and those those
numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example I was talking about
that with the car you may have 100 tests
but because the wind's blowing it's all
over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data is going to
also cause this problem we only have a
few points and you try to plot
everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked and
so you have to go back break it up and
find out actually what correlates and
what doesn't
so what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models can neither
learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as a model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern uh we just kind of accept
everything
data use for training is not cleaned and
contains noise garbage and values again
under fitting and overfitting same issue
you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias
we've seen this in all kinds of things
from
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have five people from India and 10
people from Africa and 20 people from
the U.S you've created a bias because
it's looking at the 20 people and you
only have a small amount of data to work
with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size I was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs as a slight
shift to it for other reasons
what is a good fit
a linear curve that best fits the data
is neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting lines
going up and down every point is trying
to be include glueded under fitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that error
coming through regularization is taking
the guesswork out you're looking at this
graph and you're going oh which one is
that really overfit or is that under fit
that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
underfitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the Ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the MLP the multi-layered
positron in the SK learn module you
could bring in the ridge module and you
can bring in the lasso module
so when we talk about
um Ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares or the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals Lambda times the sum of W
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either Square it or we absolute value
it because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our uh um in this case
the Lambda is going to be the penalty
for the errors we've thrown in a Greek
character for you just to confuse
everybody and W is the slope of the
curve of the line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sklearn you could import
just a standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this and of course we're
just extrapolating this I know they use
some specific data but we don't want to
get into the actual domain and so for a
linear regression line let's consider
two points that are on the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero considering the two points
on the line we'll go ahead and do Lambda
equals one let's head our W is going to
be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so really don't get caught up too much
in the math on this other than
understanding that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the Lambda times W the sum
is W squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when we put
all the calculations through of the two
points we end up with the 0.0 0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model it plots
a little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and I find this true on a lot of data I
work with I'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso Mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals instead of
doing a squared we're just going to do
the absolute value and so if you
remember this is where Ridge regression
changes where's my Ridge regression
model we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
um and here is our
Lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and W equals the slope of the Curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like I said I use these two
models a lot uh the Ridge and this is
important this is this is kind of the
meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out Ridge
regularization is useful when we have
many variables with relatively smaller
data samples the model does not
encourage convergence towards zero but
is likely to make them closer to zero
and prevent overfitting
the Lasser regularization model is
preferred when we are fitting a linear
model with fewer variables
so in the LA in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as we measure the
different Leaf pieces uh you might be
doing the measurements on the cancer
project which has 36 different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables lasso lar will probably work
pretty good where you might use the
ridge regularization with more model
with if you have something significantly
larger and it encourages the
coefficients of the variables to go
towards zero because of the shape of the
constraint which is an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and uh do a demo in lasso in Ridge
regression so let's take a look and see
what that looks like in our code and
bring up our Jupiter notebook
we'll start with our Imports pandas is
PD import numpy is NP import matplot
Library as PLT SK learn we're going to
import our data sets it's kind of more
generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
uh we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up and then
we'll bring in our linear regression
model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up and then load our data set
we're just talking about that you could
just have imported the load Boston and
Boston data set in there instead of
loading all the data sets
um
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and I'm going to run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
Boston data we're going to load we put
it into our pandas data frame
um the Boston data set and then the
Boston columns we want to see what's
going on with them we have our Target we
have the house price uh Etc and so our x
equals Boston
um I location
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want I location if you're
going to pull data we used to be able to
leave this off but it does something
different it creates a slice versus a
direct setup so make sure using that I
location and the I the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the Boston
Panda's head we can see here all of our
different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the X and the Y
the x is everything
except for the last column
where Y is uh all the that's what this
means all the roads except for the last
column and then Y is all the rows but
just the last column so Y is our house
price and the x is the crimesean
industry Chas Knox and all these other
different statistics they've collected
for house sales in Boston
foreign
there we go oops control
ah
so we'll go ahead and split our data uh
X train and our X test y train y test
equals the train test split which we
imported
and we have our Boston you could have
easily used the X and Y on here as
opposed to Boston I location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
uh and then we'll go ahead and run this
uh
need an extra drink there uh so we have
our training test and then of course the
print the train data shape
I love doing this kind of thing whenever
I'm working with this data print out the
shape make sure your everything looks
correct uh so that we have 127 by 13 and
127 by one 379 by 13. they should match
and if they're if the the data sets are
not quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors I
don't know how many times I've gone
through here and it's dropped a row on
one of them and not on the other or
something weird has happened when I'm
cleaning the data this is pretty
straightforward and simple because the
data comes in a nice pre-packaged is all
clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and uh we'll call this lreg El reg
linear regression and we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to X train and Y train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set so here's our L reg y
predict
with our X test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error MSE I told you you'll see MSC used
a lot people use it in variables and
things like that it's pretty common and
we get our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up but if it's
not it's just a bunch of numbers and
that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo and
then we're going to go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here
um
when we plot the coefficient scores on
here
and we the guys in the back did a great
job putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here uh your knocks has like
just a huge coefficient
when I look at a table like this I look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that plagues you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and bring them down as much as we can
and for that we're going to work with
the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our Ridge model
the red regression from the sklearn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our Ridge R equals
Alpha equals one and I mentioned that
earlier
when I work with the ridge model you'll
see Alpha equals one if you said Alpha
equal to zero that's the standard linear
regression model so you have Alpha
equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four in a
standard integer on there and we'll go
ahead and fit the ridge model on there
with our X train and our y train data
generate a prediction for that for our X
test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now if I jump up and down between these
two
you'll get a headache
you'll still see the Knox value let's
just look at the knocks because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the Knox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat I'm
seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient there
uh so if we're going to do that nice
setup we want to go ahead and just print
it and see what that looks like
here we go and we've set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good we're doing an X bar based on the
columns
and our L regress coefficients color
equals color X spine bottom and so forth
uh so just puts together a nice little
graph
and you're starting to see one this when
you compare this if you put on the same
graph as this one up here this is a pure
minus 18. this is at minus nine and so
this graph is half the size of the graph
above the same thing with these values
here
they might look the same but they're
actually all almost half the value on
here
finally you can do the same thing for
the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and I'm just going ahead and print that
on here and run it
and again let's go up to Knox
look where Knox is it's all the way down
to zero and if we look at our next
biggest coefficient it's minus 0.8 and
really
here's our 22.73 let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number 16.69
and so we look at this uh if I was
running this and doing a working on a
project with this I would look at these
numbers I start with the 16.69 come down
here and compare it to
16.78 69 is better than 7 8 so from the
very beginning we might start looking at
this first model for overall predicting
but there's other factors involved we
might know that uh the Knox value is
Central and the other ones aren't quite
as good and so we might start looking at
just certain setups like what is our
what is this particular coefficient
because it might have a certain meaning
to us and so forth and so you look at
all those different items in there again
but the bottom dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set
um
continues to come down on this
dimensionality reduction dimensionality
reduction refers to the technique that
reduces the number of input variables in
a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company bpacs isomax and they have
the item the tire the axle an order ID a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells we find out
that using correlation analysis that we
just need three attributes therefore we
have reduced the number of attributes
from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number I don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time that can be really
important if you're trying a number of
different models uh and you're rewriting
them over and over again and even if you
have seven gigabytes of data that can
start taking days to go through all
those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing our data
set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just one so when you get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data pool we might not send the company
that bought it why would we want to
store two whole extra columns when we
add it into that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2D
and 3D plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting you want to be able
to give them a really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in postcribing leads
to better human interpretation that kind
of goes with number four what makes data
easy for plotting you have a better
interpretation we're looking at it
principal component analysis so what is
it
uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the PCA we
reduce the variables we end up with the
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here let's
say you are asked to take a picture of
some Toddlers and you are deciding which
angle would be the best to take the
picture from so if we come up here we
look at this we say okay this is you
know one angle we get the back of a lot
of heads not many faces so we'll do it
from here we might get the one person up
front smiling a lot of the people in the
class are missing so we have a huge
amount off to the right a blank space
Maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it and you
say hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical formula so it's consistent
and so it makes sense in the back end
one of the projects I worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris and if
you've ever done the iris data set it's
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower
and they're measuring the stamina in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the width to length ratio we
can divide the width by the length and
you get a single number where you had
two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my uh
Iris petal example
when we look at the similarity in PCA we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there we can see
these data points based on in this case
just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36 40
variables almost all of your business
models usually have about 26 to 27
different variables they're looking at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the X Y
we look down at it and we have our
second idea PC2 and again we're looking
at the x i this X Y this time from a
different direction here for our E's we
can consider that we get two principal
components namely pc1 and PC2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have pc1 you can see along the line how
the data points are spaced versus the
spacing in PC2 and that's what they're
coming up with what is going to give us
the best look for these data points when
we combine them and we're looking at it
from just a single angle
whereas in PC2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
PC2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how PCA analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under a PCA
and important terminology is our views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a PCA presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
Dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
we talked about you'll hear features
Dimensions
um and I was talking about features
there's usually when you're running a
business you're talking 25 26 27
different features minimal and then you
have the principal component new
variables that are constructed as linear
combinations or mixtures of the initial
variables
principle component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the width
over the length of the petal as opposed
to putting both width and length in you
just put in the ratio instead which is a
single number versus two separate
numbers projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features you're trying to reduce them so
that's just kind of goofy but it is
important to remember that people will
throw weird code out there and just
randomly do stuff with instead of really
thinking it through principle components
are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line uh
same thing with PC2 and we want to make
sure that pc1 does not equal PC2 we
don't want to have the same two
principal points when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to create
uh one principle
component everything is summarized into
that one component as we go to two
components the priority how much it
holds value decreases as we go down so
if you have five different points each
one of those points is going to have
less value than just the one point which
has everything summarized in it how PCA
works
I said there was more in the back end we
talk about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you
know you're looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
Works PCA performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our I Gene
vectors and I Gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the I Gene Vector is like a
translation if we're moving the data
from x equals 1 to x equals 2 or
whatever we're altering it and the
hygiene value is the final value that we
generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them lie within similar
boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have Z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
The covariance Matrix computation
covariance Matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
The covariance Matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by VAR and the covariance is denoted by
Cove
on the right we can see the covariance
Matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a Hands-On look at the code
we'll do a display of this so you can
see what we're talking about and what
that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature or two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going on
and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different variables
covariance Matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the Aging values and
the Aging vectors
iodine values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value that are
extracted from the covariance table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components iodine vectors do not change
directions after linear transformation I
Gene values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the I Gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so we have like
multiple variables how do we calculate
that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has
hygiene vectors of the components that
we decide to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps this becomes really
important as we start looking at the
back end of this and we'll do this in
the demo but one of the more important
steps to understand
and so we have the PCA example consider
Matrix X within rows or observations and
K columns or variables now for this
Matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our Simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation rho of the Matrix X
is placed in the K dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principle component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm it represents the maximum
variance Direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
PC2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means inside our python
scripting
I'm going to use the Anaconda Navigator
and I will be in Python 3.6 for this
example I believe there's even like a
3.9 out
I tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models I use especially with the
neural networks are stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our Jupiter I'm in
Chrome and we go ahead and create a new
python 3.
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing I like to do
whenever I'm looking at any new setup uh
well you know what Let's do let's do the
libraries first we're going to do our
basic libraries which is matplot Library
uh the PLT from the matplot library
pandas our data frame PD numpy our
numbers array NP Seaborn for graphing
SNS that goes with the plot that
actually sits on matplot Library so the
Seaborn sits on there
and then we have our Amber sign because
we're in Jupiter notebook matplot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but I put
it in there either anyway just because
I'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set and one of the
reasons the cancer data set is it has
like 36 35 different features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
then we'll go ahead and run this and
look at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set is we have
our data we have our Target our frame
Target names description feature names
and file name
so what we're looking for in all this
is let's take a look at the description
let's go in here and pull up the
description on here
I'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our PCA setup what's important is you
start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean if you
were in the medical field you'd want to
note all these different things whether
what they're measuring where it's coming
from
you can actually see the actual
different uh measurements are taking
no missing attributes
let me page all the way to the bottom
and you're going to have your data in
this case our Target
and if you dig deep enough to the Target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print Target names
real quick here I always like to to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
uh
Target
names
run that
and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 so in other words
is this uh dangerous growth or is it
something we don't have to worry about
that's the bottom line with the cancer
in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and you know what let me go up a
just a notch here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right I guess
I'll be up to do uh so let's go ahead
and look at our data uh our we're going
to use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the names up of
our of the features in there what is
going to come out of this let me just
see if we can get to that
it's at the top of Target names
um that's just this list of names here
in the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture mean perimeter
I don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because like many of the data
that most the data that comes in half
the time we don't even know what we're
looking at we're just handed a bunch of
stuff as a data scientist going what the
heck is this and so this is a good place
to start because this has a number of
different features in there we have no
idea what these feature means or where
they come from we want to just look at
the data and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
PCA side of it as we've noticed before
it's difficult to visualize High
dimensional data we can use PCA to find
the first two principal components and
visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot before we do this we need
to go ahead and scale our data
now
I haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time I almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA but just in
case it's always good to scale it
and then we're going to take our PCA
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead I'm
going to run this code
uh so the code for this
is from sklearn decomposition import PCA
PCA equals PCA and components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
I would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders
the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can see
uh and then the PCA fit we're going to
is going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here and then you can see
we've created our PCA model with in
components equals two
now whenever I use a new tool
I like to go in there and actually see
what I'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the PCA
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be well the biggest one is your
components how many components do you
want which you have to put in there
pretty much and then you also might look
at the SVD solver it's on auto right now
but you can override that and do
different things with it it does a
pretty good job as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
um
there we go to our methods
if you notice we have fit we have fit
transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction it's used to
look at the data again we're in the
describe setup we're fitting the data
we're taking a look at it we've already
looked at our minimum maximum we've
already looked at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing the data
that's the biggest thing I take away
when I come zooming in here and of
course they have examples of it down
here if you forget
um and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then uh I mean
the rest you can play with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full randomize there's different things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to PCA
transform scaled data
uh so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us uh what's going on here
we've taken 30 features I think I said
36 or something like that but it's 30.
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from we saw on two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and uh
we're just going to use our PLT figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot xpca X underscore PCA
of uh of one these are two different
perceptions we're using uh and then
you'll see right here C for color cancer
equals Target and so remember we have
zero we have one
and if I remember correctly zero was
malignant one was B9 uh so everything in
the zero column is going to be one color
and the other color is going to be one
and then we're going to use the plasma
map just kind of telling you what color
it is add some labels first principle
component second principle component and
we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different columns in it we can look at
this and say hey this one actually did a
pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when I'm looking at
this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area or it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign and we
have a huge area it's still clumped
together more spread out where it's
going to be malignant or I think I have
that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case cancer we would try
to separate I would be exploring how to
separate this middle group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it just
because those are the people you want to
go in there and have extra tests or
treat it differently versus going in and
saying just cutting into the can into
the cancer so the body absorbs it and it
dissipates versus uh actively going in
there removing it testing it going
through chemo and all the different
things that's a big difference you know
as far as what's going to happen here in
that middle line where the overlap is
going to be huge that's domain specific
uh going back to the data we can see
here uh clearly by using these two
components we can easily separate these
two classes so the next step is what
does that mean interpreting the
components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes a cost of
not being able to easily understand what
these components represent
I don't know a principle component one
looks represents or second principle the
components correspond to combinations of
original features the components
themselves are stored as an attribute of
the filtered PCA object and so we talk
look at that we can go ahead and do look
at the PCA components this is in our
model we built we've trained it we can
run that and you can see here's the
actual components it's the two
components have each have their own
array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using and these
actually give weight to what features
are doing what
so in this numpy Matrix array each row
represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing what this means and so
let me go ahead and just put this down
oops I already got it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our DF comp data
frame and we do our PCA components
and I want you to notice how easy this
is uh we're going to set our columns
equal to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's needed about a data frame is when
we get to Seabourn it will pull that
data frame apart in and set it up for us
when we want and so we're just going to
do the CIA the Seabourn heat map of our
data frame composition and we'll use a
plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here you can see we have the mean radius
and all the different features along the
bottom on the right we have a scale so
we can see we have the dark colors all
the way to the really light colors which
are what's really shining there this is
like the primary stuff we want to look
at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius look how how
on the bottom of the map it is
um on some of this uh so you have some
interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh postscribe you can also use this to
try to guess as what these things mean
what you want to change to get a better
result in this session we will briefly
understand what coronavirus really is
and the various symptoms of Coronavirus
then we look at the global impact of
coronavirus in terms of the total cases
the deaths reported the fatality rate
and the tests carried out so far by
different countries after that we will
perform an analysis using svm and
polynomial regression in Python to
predict the number of upcoming cases
from the 28th of April to the 17th of
May the data we have taken is from the
22nd of January to the 27th of April
then we will analyze the model using
charts and graphs and finally we will
discuss the various safety measures you
can take to ensure you are safe and not
attacked by Coronavirus so what is
Coronavirus coronavirus or covid-19 is
an infectious disease caused by a newly
discovered coronavirus that is believed
to have emerged from a seafood market in
Wuhan China during December 2019.
it is zoonotic so it's a disease that
can be transmitted from animals to
people or more specifically a disease
that normally exists in animals but that
can infect humans too
the virus that causes covid-19 is mainly
transmitted through droplets generated
when an infected person coughs sneezes
or exhales
these droplets are too heavy to hang in
the air and quickly fall on Floors or
surfaces
it appears that symptoms show up in
people within 14 days of exposure to the
virus
with that now let's look at the various
symptoms of covid-19
a patient with Coronavirus can show
generic symptoms such as cough fever
shortness of breath and muscle pain
they can also have a sore throat
headache and loss of taste or smell
they are also expected to have Middle
East Respiratory Syndrome or MERS
and severe acute respiratory syndrome or
SARS Middle East Respiratory Syndrome is
a viral respiratory illness caused by a
Coronavirus
it is a contagious sometimes fatal
respiratory illness
it often spreads through close contact
with an infected person
SARS is contagious and sometimes fatal
respiratory illness caused by a
coronavirus it appeared in 2009 in China
it spread worldwide within a few months
although it was quickly contained
SARS is a virus transmitted through
droplets that enters the air when
someone with the disease coughs sneezes
or talks
now let's look at the impact of
coronavirus worldwide
the maps and the charts that I am going
to show you now have been taken from an
organization called our world in data
they lastly focus on problems that the
world faces such as poverty different
diseases hunger climate change
existential crisis and inequality
their main goal is to research and use
data to make progress against the
world's largest problems the map that
you see on your screens shows the total
number of confirmed covid-19 cases till
the 26th of April
below you can see the color scale
ranging from 0 to 1 million
the countries with the least number of
cases are marked in light orange color
the countries with cases between 5000 to
10 000 cases have been depicted using
orange color
the countries with cases above 1 lakh
are shown using red color
while those above 5 lakhs have a dark
red color
you can see from the map
African nations have fewer cases
compared to nations in Asia Europe and
America
China has close to 84 000 cases India
has around 26 500 cases as of April 26th
Iran has nearly 89 000 cases
now if you look at Australia it has
cases of around 6700
in North America the United States has
the highest number of cases which is
actually the highest throughout the
world
in South America Brazil has the maximum
number of cases
the next map shows the confirmed cases
of countries on the Asian continent
China Iran turkey India and Saudi Arabia
have the highest number of cases
then we have the map of Europe
in Europe countries such as Italy France
Germany the United Kingdom Spain and
Russia have the highest number of cases
moving ahead you can see a graph of
certain selected countries and the total
confirmed cases
I have filtered out the total World
cases than countries like the United
States Spain Italy Germany France China
and India
you will learn how to create a similar
graph when we will do our prediction
analysis
let's now have a look at the total
number of daily confirmed cases
so on the 26th of April the United
States had around 48 500 cases Russia
had around 6000 cases Brazil had nearly
5 500 cases followed by the United
Kingdom with close to 5000 cases
the number of confirmed cases is lower
than the number of total cases
the reason being limited testing in
different countries across the world
now looking at the total debts reported
across the world on this map the United
States has the highest number with over
53 000 deaths so far followed by Italy
France the United Kingdom and Germany
next you can see a graph of a few
countries and the total death cases till
the 26th of April
you can see the United States Spain
Italy France China and India here
we will see how to build a similar graph
in our demo
up next on your screens is the map of
different countries and their fatality
rate
fatality rate is actually the ratio
between the confirmed debts and
confirmed cases
France has the highest fatality rate
with over 18.22 percent followed by the
United Kingdom at 13.69 percent and
Italy at 13.51 percent
moving ahead the next map shows the
total number of covid-19 test numbers
the United States has conducted over 5
million tests so far followed by Russia
with over 2.88 million tests Germany
turkey Canada and India have been
conducting covid-19 tests in large
numbers to deal with the situation
now each country is dealing with this
pandemic within its own capacity to make
sure the situation doesn't worsen most
affected countries have gone for a
lockdown
but does Lockdown work well the research
says yes
on the screens you can see the number of
days some countries have enforced a
partial or full lockdown to curb the
spread of Coronavirus
this information has been taken from one
of India's leading media groups India
Today data intelligence unit
the orange color represents full
lockdown while the yellow color adapt
its partial lockdown
countries like Australia India Belgium
the United Kingdom China the United
States France Spain and others already
have announced lockdown for more than 40
days
to make sure the lockdowns don't extend
further and the situation improves
people are being advised to stay at home
and avoid public gatherings
now let's look at where India stands
with its battle for Coronavirus as per
the Press information Bureau of India or
pib
here are the figures and the situation
report till 5 PM on the 26th of April
the states that have been affected the
most are Maharashtra Gujarat Delhi
madhya Pradesh uttar Pradesh and Tamil
Nadu
Maharashtra has over 7600 cases followed
by Gujarat with over 3000 cases
Maharashtra also has the highest number
of deaths reported which stands at 323
next is Gujarat with 133 followed by
madhya Pradesh at 99 deaths so far
there are still 312 cases yet to be
assigned to the states which are under
the process of contact tracing
you can see on the top there are more
than 27 000 confirmed cases in India out
of which 20 177 are Active cases
more than 6000 people have recovered
from coronavirus while the death tally
stands at 872.
the government is doing its best to
control the situation please follow the
rules and guidelines issued by the local
and Central authorities this will help
us fight the situation together
effectively now coming to the most
important part of this session which you
guys have been waiting for a while
the coronavirus outbreak prediction
analysis
we will analyze the outbreak of
coronavirus in the coming days across
various countries worldwide visualize
them using charts and graphs and predict
the number of upcoming cases for the
next 20 days using polynomial regression
and support Vector machines model in
Python our data has information from the
22nd of January to the 28th of April
the data sets we will be using are taken
from the repository operated by the
Johns Hopkins University Center of
system science and engineering
let me show you where you can locate the
data sets
so here is the GitHub repository where
you can find the data sets and a few
other resources
it is being updated on a regular basis
I would encourage you to go through this
link once
now
let me take you to the jupyter notebook
where I have already implemented the
course I'll run through it and explain
each cell of code to make you understand
what it does
so this is my jupyter notebook
first we will import all the libraries
necessary for this analysis
we are importing the numpy and pandas
that are used for numerical computations
data manipulation and data analysis
then I am importing the matplotlib
library for creating data visualizations
next I'm also going to import random
math and time libraries
after that from the sqln library I'm
importing the linear regression model as
well as certain functions such as train
test split and polynomial features to
build our polynomial regression
svr will help us create the support
Vector machines model
we will also use SQL Matrix to import
functions such as mean squared error
mean absolute error and so on
this we will use for calculating the
accuracy of our model
let me now run this cell by hitting
shift plus enter
so you can see we have successfully run
the first cell
now
we will load our data sets
we'll be using three data sets for this
demo
the data sets are present in a GitHub
repository maintained by Johns Hopkins
University to import the data sets I
have used the pandas library and read
underscore CSV function
I provided the URL location of the files
followed by the file name and the
extension of the file which is dot CSV
I have loaded these three data sets to
three variable names
now let's run the cells to import all
the three data sets
so first I've imported the confirmed
cases data set
now to display the data set I am using
the dot head function to see the top
five rows from the data
if I scroll down
you can see our confirmed underscore
cases data set
we are displaying the first five rows
from the data set
it has information like Province or the
state country or the region the latitude
the longitude
and the date value starting from 22nd of
January to the 27th of
April
now let me go ahead and import the debts
underscore reported data set
and now to display the data set I have
used the dotted function
so this is how
the deaths data set looks like
let me now go ahead
and import the recovered underscore
cases data set
and now to display the head of the data
set
so here is how the recovered
data set looks like or the recoveries
data set looks like
finally I load the data set which is all
the latest updates from across the globe
regarding confirmed cases that's
recovered and Active cases
let's see the head of this latest data
set
as you can see it has information about
the province or the state country or the
region
when it was last updated
the latitude and the longitude of the
location
and it has data regarding the confirmed
cases the deaths reported
the recovered cases the Active cases and
so on
after that I'm extracting all the column
names from the confirmed cases data
frame using the dot Keys function
if I run this
below you can see we have
all the column names
next
we are extracting only the date columns
that have information of confirmed cases
death cases and recovered cases using
the dot loc function
we are storing it in respective
variables
the first parameter that is colon
tells us we need all the rows from the
data
while the second parameter tells us we
need the data from the fourth column
till the last column
which are the date values
let me run it
let's check the confirmed variable and
see what it has
you can see it has the date columns from
the 22nd of Jan
till the 27th of April
in the next cell of code I'm basically
creating multiple empty lists to find
the total cases worldwide the total
number of deaths so far the mortality
rate the recovered cases and the total
Active cases
I also want to find out the confirmed
cases deaths and recoveries for few
countries such as China Italy United
States Spain France Germany UK Russia
and India
so I have created empty lists for these
countries as well we will see how to
append values to this empty list in the
next step
let me just run it
Now using a for loop I am finding the
total sum of confirmed cases death cases
and recoveries made so far
these values I am appending to the empty
lists World cases total deaths total
recovered and total Active cases
the total Active cases are calculated as
the confirmed cases minus the death
cases minus the recovered cases
now to calculate the mortality rate I am
using a simple formula which is the sum
of the total debts divided by the total
confirmed cases
the recovery rate is also calculated by
dividing the total recovered cases with
the total confirmed cases
then
I am appending the values of confirmed
cases for each country using the append
function and selecting different
countries for which we had created an
empty list
similarly I am also appending the values
for deaths and recoveries made for each
of these countries
let's run it
now you can check the world cases each
day
so
these are the world cases that have come
up each day
and you can see the number has reached
almost 30 lakhs now
then you can see the total death so far
globally
so these are the debts
reported each day across the globe
you can see
there have been around
more than 2 lakhs casualties so far
let me collapse it
next I'm printing out the total sum of
confirmed cases
so you can see it stands at around 30
lakhs 41 764.
similarly let me print out the total
debt sum
so it's around 2 lakhs 11
167 as of 27th of April
now also checked the recovered sum
it's around 8 lakhs 93 967
you can also have a look at the cases
based on individual countries
so here you can see the cases that have
come up so far in the United States
which is U.S underscore cases
so United States has nearly 9 lakhs 88
197 cases
let me collapse it
now let's check for India as well
so in India the total cases
have reached 29 451
let me collapse it further
you can also have a look at the
recoveries for each country here I am
printing out the recoveries made in
Italy
foreign
for understanding the daily increase in
cases across the world the daily
casualties and the daily recovery cases
for that
I am using a user defined function to
track the daily increase
let me run it
okay
now to find the total worldwide increase
in cases I am calling the above created
user defined function and assigning it
to World daily increase variable
similarly I am using the same method to
find the daily increase in cases for
different countries
let me show you the daily increase in
confirmed cases for Spain
so yesterday that is 27th of April Spain
had
2793 cases
now let's check for Germany also
as you can see yesterday Germany had
around 988 cases
in the next cell I am finding out the
daily death cases across the world as
well as for a few countries
let me run it
let's check the daily deaths that have
been reported in China
so these are the values of daily deaths
in China
you can see the numbers have
significantly reduced
Also let's check for the United Kingdom
as well
so on 27th of April United Kingdom had
363 deaths reported
moving ahead I'm also calculating the
daily recovery cases across the world
and for some countries
now let's go ahead and check the data
from India in terms of the daily
recovery cases
so these are the values
and if I scroll down you can see
yesterday that is 27th of April India
had 614 recovered cases
Also let's have a look at the world
recovery cases
here you can see on 27th of April nearly
28 234 people have recovered across the
globe
with that the next step is to visualize
our data so first I am finding out the
list of unique countries using the list
function
and passing the latest data variable to
filter the different uni countries
so here you can see the list of
different countries
now the cell that you see on your
screens
we are using these lines of code to find
the country's confirmed cases the death
cases Active cases recovery cases and
mortality rate
we are finding the sum of the cases and
appending it to empty list that we have
created
we are also removing the countries that
have no cases at all and finally we are
sorting the countries by the number of
confirmed cases
so let me run it
in this cell
you will be visualizing the data using a
gradient styled color map to see the
country name the number of confirmed
cases and the number of deaths the
number of recoveries and so on
I have taken blue as my gradient
let me run it
as you can see
we have an interesting table that looks
really attractive
on the left you can see the country
names
the table has been sorted in descending
order of confirmed cases
you can see the dark blue color depicts
the countries with the highest number of
cases
in this case it's United States
then we have Spain Italy and France
we also have Germany and United Kingdom
you can also see the number of deaths
and recoveries in the middle of this
table
and to the right you can see the number
of active cases and the mortality rate
you can see from the visual
Italy has the highest mortality rate
followed by the United Kingdom
similarly
I am finding out the list of unique
provinces using the list function and
passing the latest data variable to
filter out different provinces
in the next cell we are finding the
confirmed cases the death cases Active
cases recovery cases and mortality rate
for each province of a particular
country
we're also finding the sum of the cases
and appending it to empty list that we
have created
we are also removing the provinces that
have no cases at all
and finally we are sorting the provinces
by the number of confirmed cases
so let's run it
in this cell we will be visualizing the
data of different provinces using a
gradient styled color map to see the
province or the state names the number
of confirmed cases the number of debts
number of recoveries and so on
I have taken red as my gradient
let's run it
there you go
we have our visual here on the screen
New York state has the highest number of
confirmed cases
and the number of deaths as well
The hube Province in China
has had the highest recoveries which is
around
63 604
and to the extreme right you can see the
mortality rate
the next cell of code deals with
handling missing values or Nan values
it is important to handle such values
otherwise your data would be noisy and
messy and it will lead to inappropriate
results
now
I am plotting a horizontal bar graph to
compare the number of cases in the
United States and outside of United
States
the outside United States cases have
been calculated by subtracting the
United States confirmed cases from the
country confirmed cases worldwide
I have used
plt.bar H function to plot my horizontal
bars
we have also given a title to this plot
let me run it
so this is my bar graph
the blue bar represents the United
States confirmed cases
and the Red Bar represents the cases
outside of United States
now if you want to print the actual
values of the cases in the United States
and outside of United States you can do
that too
as you can see
there are nearly 19 lakhs 58 592 cases
outside of United States
in United States there are nearly 9
lakhs 38 154 cases and the total cases
stand at 28 lakhs 96 746 cases
then I want to sue only 10 countries
with the most confirmed cases
the rest I want to group it into the
others category
so using two empty lists I am going to
find out the top 10 countries with the
highest number of cases the remaining I
am categorizing under others
now to show these countries I have
defined a function
that will plot my horizontal bar graph
let me run it
Now using plot underscore bar underscore
graphs function we will create the bar
graph
I have used the visual underscore unique
underscore countries and visual
underscore confirmed underscore cases
variables and given a title to the graph
so here is our horizontal bar graph you
can see the United States has the
highest number of cases
the next is Spain
the United Kingdom is at the sixth
position
Russia is at the 10th Place
and on the top you can see the others
category as well
now we will create a pie chart to plot
the same graph
for that I have created another function
called plot underscore Pi underscore
charts
let me just run it
Now using plot underscore Pi underscore
charts function name we will create the
pie chart I've again used visual
underscore unique underscore countries
and visual underscore confirmed
underscore cases variables and given a
title to the graph
there you go we have our pie chart on
the screen
and on the right you can see the legend
which shows the different country names
the maximum area in the pie chart has
been occupied by United States
then we have the others category
followed by
Spain Italy and France
I'll follow the same procedure to show
10 provinces with the most confirmed
cases the rest I will group into the
others category for that I will be using
2m10 lists
visual underscore unique underscore
provinces and visual underscore
confirmed underscore cases 2.
let's plot the graph using plot
underscore bar underscore graphs
function
so here you can see the bar graph
New York Province or the New York state
has the highest number of cases
then we have New Jersey
followed by Yuba Province in China and
Massachusetts
and on the top you can see the others
category
the next cell of code
looks pretty complicated
it is essentially trying to plot a pie
chart for different countries along with
its several States and provinces
here we want to show only the top 10
states with the highest number of cases
let me run it
now
I want to show the pie chart for the
United States and its top 10 states
let me do that
foreign
as you can see we have our pie chart and
on the right you can see we have the
legend for 10 states
so the maximum area in the pie chart has
been occupied by
New York and then
we have the other
States
next is New Jersey followed by
Massachusetts and California
let me also check the confirmed cases
for different states in France
I'll change this to
France
so here is our pie chart
which has
10 different states in France
with that let's now come to building our
model using polynomial regression and
support Vector machines
in this step I am converting all the
dates and the cases in the form of a
numpy array using the NP dot array
function
let's run it
since our prediction will be for the
next 20 days so I have created a
variable called days underscore future
and I have assigned a value of 20. then
I'm adding the last 20 days to the total
number of days we have
now let me show you the values of future
underscore forecast
so here
it's a list of values basically is the
number of total D's
next we are converting all the integers
into date time values for better
visualization
now it's time to split our data into
training and testing sets for that I am
using the train underscore test
underscore split function
I have taken days since 22nd of Jan and
the world cases as my parameters
I'll be using 75 percent of data for
training the model and 25 percent for
testing the model
we will now transform our data for
polynomial regression for that I will
use the polynomial features function and
fit underscore transform method to
transform our training testing and
future forecast data
next I will build the polynomial
regression model using the linear
regression function and I have used the
linear underscore model.fit function to
fit the training data after that
I have used the predict function to
predict the test data set values
finally I am printing the mean absolute
error value and the mean squared error
value as well
so you can see the results here
let's now plot the graph between the
test data set and the values from the
predicted polynomial regression model
So Below you can see the graph here
the Blue Line represents the test data
and the red line represents our
polynomial regression predictions
now let's start building our model using
a support Vector machines algorithm
svm uses different parameters to build a
model these parameters are kernel C
gamma Epsilon shrinking and svm
underscore grid
kernel specifies the kernel type to be
used in the algorithm
it must be one of linear poly RBF
sigmoid pre-computed or callable
if nothing is given RBF will be used by
default
C is a regularization parameter gamma is
the kernel coefficient of RBF poly and
sigmoid
Epsilon specifies the Epsilon tube
within which no penalty is associated in
the training loss function
shrinking takes Boolean values true or
false svm grid has all the values
parameters passed to it here we are
creating the support vector regressors
and then using the fit function to fit
our training data set finally we are
predicting the values for future data as
well
let me now print the Mae and the MSC
values and display the graph of the
prediction
as you can see
the Blue Line represents the test data
and the red line represents the svm
predictions
now let's create some more
visualizations to understand the model
and our data better
here I am plotting the number of
coronavirus cases over time I've used
the adjusted dates and the world cases
to plot the graph
I've also assigned the X labels and the
Y labels
let me run it
as you can see from the graph
the total number of cases
have reached close to
30 lakhs now
next
in this graph we are showing the total
number of coronavirus deaths over time
I have also used the X label and the Y
label
you can see the total number of deaths
have reached over
2 lakhs
similarly in the next graph
we can see the total number of recovered
cases which are more than 8 lakhs
then
we are also looking at the total number
of active cases across the globe
so here is the graph for that
you can see the number of coronavirus
Active cases over time
I am now creating a bar graph with
adjusted dates and the world daily
increase as my variables
as you can see on some of the days the
cases have gone very high reaching
hundred thousand in a d
the next graph we are plotting to show
the world daily increase in confirmed
death cases
so here is the bar graph for that
you can see there are certain days that
have reported more than 10 000 deaths in
a day
the next graph shows the world daily
increase in confirmed recovery cases
so here is the graph for that
moving ahead I'll plot the graphs to
show the number of coronavirus cases
over time
let's now plot the actual graph
I have taken adjusted underscore dates
World cases linear underscore trade
variables as my parameter
let me run it
you can see this is our graph
the Blue Line represents the confirmed
we will check for the SDM model as well
So Below is the graph
again the now
let me print out the predicted values
from the polynomial regression model as
a data frame
so you can see
we have our predicted
confirmed cases for the next 20 days
that is from the 28th of April to the
17th of May
likewise
let me also print out the predicted
values for the SVO model as a data frame
so here are
predicted values from the svm model
in the next graph we are plotting the
debts and the recoveries in the same
graph
so here is our line graph
you can see clearly the number of
recoveries are way higher than the
number of deaths which is actually a
good sign
moving forward
the next graph shows a line chart with
the number of coronavirus deaths versus
the number of coronavirus recoveries
so here is the graph
the x-axis has the number of recoveries
and the y-axis has the number of total
debts
now this cell of code looks pretty huge
we want to plot the total number of
confirmed cases the daily increase in
confirmed cases the increase in debts
and the increase in recoveries for
different countries across the globe
let me run this cell
so using the country underscore plot
function that was defined above we will
be plotting the data for various
countries
let me start with China first
so you can see there are four graphs in
total if I scroll down the first you see
here is China confirmed cases
next is the China daily increase in
confirmed cases
so you can see in one of the days it had
a huge Spike
in the increase in confirmed cases then
we have the China daily increase in
debts
and finally we have the daily increase
in recoveries
now let's check for Italy
let me scroll down you can see the same
plots for Italy as well the first we
have total confirmed cases in Italy
which is nearly around
2 lakhs
then we have the daily increase in
confirmed cases
next we have the Italy
daily increase in debts
and finally we have the increase in
recoveries
let's have a look at how the graphs for
India looks like
you see the total well
let's also see for the United States
so here you can see all the four graphs
for the United States
Spain France Germany and in and they
have been depicted using different
colors
on the top left you can see the legend
now this graph looks similar to the one
that we saw in our slides
next I am plotting the total coronavirus
dead
so here is our graph
finally let us look at the total
coronavirus cases in these countries
the last three graphs look similar to
what we have used in the slides from our
world in data
now it's my responsibility to call out
all the safety precautions that you
should take to make sure you are safe
from being attacked by Coronavirus
first and foremost do not panic
during these unprecedented times if you
feel you are showing symptoms of
coronavirus do not wait please consult a
doctor immediately
stay at home to ensure you are not
exposed to the virus outside
maintain social distancing with people
if you are talking to someone outside
and if someone is sick
do not forget to wash your hands
regularly using soaps sanitizers and
other disinfectants
always remember to wear a mask while you
are going outside
make sure to practice respiratory
hygiene such as cover your mouth while
coughing and try eating healthy food all
these precautions will help you avoid
coronavirus and make sure you are safe
and healthy now moving on to the final
section let me tell you how simple learn
can help you start your career in
machine learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so I am on the Chrome browser
let me search for simplyloan.com
and here
under what you want to learn let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category
so you can see here there are multiple
courses
first let me open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so
so this is the postgraduate program in
AI in machine learning which is in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM
if I scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course
so we'll get audio Alumni Association
membership industry recognized IBM
certificates enrollment to Simply launch
job assist this 25 plus Hands-On
projects on GPU enabled Labs you have
450 Plus hours of Applied learning
caption projects in three domains and
much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this program
and you will also get certificates
recognized by IBM
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to Simply learn job
assist program so you will get IM jobs
crew membership for six months resume
assistance and career monitoring there's
interview preparation and career Affairs
if I scroll further here you can see the
learning path
and you will learn about python for data
science this machine learning deep
learning with tensorflow and carers is
Advanced deep learning and computer
vision you will also learn about natural
language processing that is NLP and
speech recognition we have reinforcement
learning and you also have the
opportunity to select a few electives so
we have IBM Watson for chatbots machine
learning with r there's git and GitHub
training
and two others
here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning we
learn about python supervised learning
this dance computer vision tensorflow
this reinforcement learning speech
recognition you will also learn about
numpy pandas and other libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if I scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on so this is on Twitter this one
on zomato one on Uber
and Mercedes-Benz as well
they are our course advisors
so please go ahead and enroll to this
postgraduate program in AI machine
learning if you want to kick start your
career in
machine learning
now the next course we have is machine
learning certification course if I
scroll down you can see the details of
this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
Hands-On exercises you will get to work
on four real life industry based
projects with integrated Labs there will
be dedicated mentoring sessions from
industry experts 44 hours of instructed
late training with certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression you will
also learn about support Vector Machines
games clustering knife base decision
trees random Forest
and you'll learn the concepts of bagging
and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the
course content
and if I scroll further now these are
the projects that you'll get to work on
and finally you'll receive this
certificate once you complete the course
thank you all for watching this full
course video tutorial on machine
learning with python I hope you liked it
if you have any questions then please
put them in the comment section our team
will help you solve your queries thanks
again stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
if you like this video subscribe to the
simply learned YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turn it up
and get certified click here